Keep it together. Keep it together
so hard to keep it together.
We just got to keep it together.
It's so important to keep it together.
I know it's hard as fuck
to keep it together,
but key pay together.
Before we get started,
we've got some shows coming up.
Brian Red Band and Tony Hinchcliffe
or making them wait Serrano.
Be careful up there. He fucks cause
that's Canada or I design America.
He's gotta be respectful.
Don't go up there.
Thrown your fucking waste products
in the street. Be Kind, be gentle.
Canadians are awesome.
You're gonna love Toronto.
Toronto.
Very different than a Vancouver.
Yeah, I think, uh, well
they're both awesome. You know,
cannabis,
like one of my favorite places to perform.
I'm doing a Winnipeg this weekend.
Wow, that's awesome. It's fucking,
they're strong. They're so fun.
They're, they're like, they're like,
just like regular, like American crowds,
like a really good American crowd.
Jazz that up like 5%.
That's like a really good Canadian crowd.
They're like super enthusiastic.
They're awesome. Sweet.
And that place that you're
going to in Toronto,
they may or may not smoke marijuana while
the show was going on underground cafe
and you may or may not not be able to
see people in the audience because you're
performing in the fucking clouds.
I heard that.
I think it was Esther or somebody went
there and they don't smoke weed and they
said that they got so stoned that they
was having a panic attack while just
doing comedy there.
Absolutely no doubt. 100% the,
there was no air left in that room.
You were only breathing we'd wow.
It was insane.
I had never been so high in my life.
There was no way or they,
there was nowhere else to go. I'd hit
the back of the high wall like, Oh,
here we are. It's like this is
the wall. This is the 300 foot or
I'm not going to, I'm not going to do
good. I, this is going to be scary for me.
I'm not going to be fine. Just don't
get too high before you go up there.
That's the thing. Just don't get too
high before you go up there. Wow.
Or do it get high like
really early in the day.
So you're comfortable around like five,
six o'clock.
You better build up your tolerance.
Yeah.
Go over your notes or just stay
with the stone is set everywhere.
I'm just making words a great though.
Great. You're doing three days up there.
July 11th to 12th and 13th.
It's a great spot.
The people that run it are super cool.
All that stuff about weed. I made that up.
It's not even going on down there. I
don't worry about it. Uh, but it's a,
you're going to love it.
And Tony Hinchcliffe we've taken with you.
It's fucking hilarious.
Really Funny Dude. He's a,
he's really coming up.
We started that new podcast with him,
the Hinch piff notes and man,
we've only done two episodes,
but I really see this becoming big.
It's like, if you know what it's like,
it's like American idol
for, uh, open makers. Yeah.
You're doing some weird shit with him.
Tell me what exactly what you're doing.
What we do is we have a show
and like whoever does they,
the comedy store has this sign up sheet
where like every Sunday or Monday you
sign up to try to do three minutes on
stage and there's tons of people that,
you know,
it's pay $20 parking.
They try to just get there three minutes
standup in and they don't get on.
So we take those people that like the
people that didn't make the standup and we
let them sign up on this list and then
they get to do one minute in front of me,
Tony and whoever the special
guests for the week is.
And then we pretty much either do
this thing called tag it or Faggot,
but spelled with a Ph. Uh, but we
changed it to valid. That's really rude.
No thought for your very first time
tagged with the p h a g thing.
That's like the whichever career
I think limit first of all guests.
You named that. Right.
Okay. And uh, second of all,
you didn't run it by any
gay friends first? No. No,
but we changed it this week to bag it.
Just because everyone got nervous.
It's unnecessary in this day and age.
Fag is unnecessary.
It's too bad cause it was cause it
was awesome. We got to let that go.
You know why we've got to let it go.
We got to let it go.
Sort of in unity to our gay friends
cause we don't really give a fuck if
someone's gay. I mean we really
don't. So like if you're,
you're saying like something homophobic
just cause it's cute and fun to do.
If you really don't care if someone's gay,
it's like you,
you're doing yourself like
a little bit of the service.
You're getting lumped in with
something that you don't agree with.
It's absolutely a, a poop joke. You
know, I'd, it's like a cheesy dumb joke,
you know,
you would say in high school.
So we changed it to bag it but last night
and what we do is we pretty much sit
there and they do their joke and
then we either help them like,
like that's a good joke. Right?
You know, here's some tags for it.
We try to tag it up for him or we just
tell them to bag it and get to get the
fuck out of area. And we kind of like
almost do it in like a roast kind of way.
But like last night we were there
and this guy came up and he's like,
and he was dressed up as iron man and
he was just came up to us and goes,
I'm a huge dose squad fan and I wanted
to come here and show and hang out with
you guys.
So He's our nut now our new security guy.
Like I like getting the people off stage.
It's not a fucking outfit. Yeah. First
of all, he's like part Ironman Park.
Captain America. Yeah. Look,
it has a microphone thing in it that's
out into battle against anyone who would
threaten our way of life.
All mine.
God, it was so ridiculous having
him on board because he was,
he ended up being really funny too.
So like he would like, you know,
give him chime in on some of the comics,
but it's,
it's the first episode drops
this week, uh, on iTunes
can go to get death squad.tv
and you can find the, uh,
how to get tickets for
the Toronto Gig. Yeah. Uh,
we're also brought to you by hover. If
you go to hover.com, forward slash Rogan,
you will save 10% off your domain name.
Registrations.
Hover is a accompany the d domain name
registration company that's owned by the
same people that own ting. And uh,
they sort of take the same approach,
try not to repeat block,
try to provide a very good service,
tried to make it easy to use and hovers.
Super easy to use.
I've used it myself to register
websites and um, their,
their user interface is very intuitive.
It's super easy.
I'm not that technical when it comes to
the Internet. I'm not like that. Like, um,
I'm not that proficient. I fuck up a lot
of feel like I'm always calling Brian.
It's like, what am I doing? What's wrong?
Like, what's wrong with my fucking phone?
What's wrong with it?
I, I don't, I don't know
that much. So if I can do it and
do it easily, it's not hard to do.
And they offer three
free things like free,
who is domain name privacy so that
if you have some disgusting website,
if you're some sick freak that
likes to beat off on feet,
there's nothing wrong with that man.
You know as long as it looks.
Some people like it. I bet. I bet they
do. Some people don't need to make a bed.
People like fat phones through their
noses and people like all kinds of crazy
shit. People like tattoo on their
face. People like crazy shit. Okay,
you can't hate,
but I don't think I should have
to know who owns that website.
And I don't think people should have
to know that you're a closet freak.
So you can have who is domain
name privacy for free with hover.
It's a cool company.
Go check it out.
hover.com forward slash Rogen and
save yourself some money because
that's my song. Boom son, go to hover.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com and what a shock because the
fucking CEO of on and is here today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
International World Traveler,
psychedelic explorer, huge cock.
That's what I hear. Well, well
easy, easy. There is no need to,
huge is a rude word except when I do a
Bogo then it shrinks to the density of
Pluto and a small diamond,
but it's t pressing his dick hole.
How dare you.
I don't think that be effective.
Maybe it would imagine if you found
that was the best way to do it,
just pack it in there like a musket
tastes like watermelon.
If you could get it like,
because there's some drugs that people
do take Ainsley and they actually enjoy
it. Like there's a girl named
neuro soup and she did a,
a a piece on youtube where
she was talking about,
it's kind of like a billion hits
because she's talking about taking Dmt,
Anal Lee, that she took DMT
and she put it in her ass.
And she was one that
was in that vice story,
that Hamilton Morris vice story where he
was talking about how her boyfriend was
his gigantic cocaine dealer,
an ecstasy dealer.
Wednesday, your Hamilton
Morris and version was
balling. That's his real voice,
man.
Don't hate.
But this chick that had this greatly
detailed vivid video about her putting,
um,
DMT in her ass and it was just fucking
super intense ride with the devil.
Yeah, I went to have watch somebody
go somebody into your bloodstream.
My parents talking to aliens that an
electronic music conference and I do not
endorse or recommend
this behavior whatsoever,
but I watched the girl who said she
couldn't get high from ecstasy anymore.
She takes one and she puts one in her
mouth and goes under her little Tutu and
puts one in her ass at the same time. And
it's like, I hope this works. Oh my God,
I hope this works. Did she at least break
it up before she wrote in her answer?
She crunched down with their butt and
try to slowly it into a fine powder,
dissolving it with the
natural juice and what? Yeah.
Why wouldn't you start
with your vagina first?
Cause it's definitely easier to get
juicy in there if you just found out that
you think you're an asshole and brain
best thing ever for cracking wallets like
you like this. No Way. My ass
has no strength. There's no,
but really you put a wall,
nothing in there and it just
destroys it and you're like, wow.
Have you ever tried to squeeze it on your
finger? No. No stick things in my ass,
but a doctor did.
Once I got,
I had a test once in a doctor looked up
my ass with his finger. I'm like, wow,
I've thought a colonic and that's
a little frightening. Yeah,
that seems like a bad idea,
right?
He had a stick a pump up up your stomach
and you're going to shoot water in
there and clean yourself out.
Including all the good stuff.
Like there's a whole civilization going
on inside your stomach. It's true.
And you're going to
blast water through your,
your shit hole and then they're gonna
examine your poop and you're going to
discuss what your diet is. Whoa, watch
it. Go through the tube, see salad.
But you said excavating.
It's like archeology, you
know, you see stratosphere,
like layers of the earth dude,
I different meals past years past,
you know you got the red layer, the
brown layer, the chain breaks off.
Just different parts that you see from
not just your last meal but many meals
before, how often you need to do it. But
that's what I saw going through the two.
Did you feel good after he did it?
The very first one I did.
I've done like a three or so.
The very first week.
It's a good excuse.
No,
the very first one I did
felt like a slight religious
experiences. Like amazing.
Like I walked out of there like feeling
light and like I was cleanse and then
the other ones were mostly
just uncomfortable and I
didn't really notice very
much reward leading me to believe that
colonics are good like once every five to
10 years or so just to kind of in case
there's some shit hiding out in some
nooks and crannies cause the digestive
tract as all these little spots and nooks
and crannies and little areas where waste
can collect and start actually really
rotting,
coming septic.
So it's good to get that out of there
every once in a while. That's my theory.
I'm just see bullshit on at Penn and
teller bullshit. What'd they say?
What'd they say? They pretty much just
went to all these doctors and like,
and you know,
had they got this guy on Craig's list
that was broken in the aid that you gave
him for like $300 to do it and
let them film it. Oh my God,
this poor guy. So then they went, all
the doctors and their doctors are like,
that's, it doesn't, nothing.
That seems silly.
There seemed to be not paying attention
and they let you watch it. Maybe that's
the next product we'll go with on it.
On a colonic. Colonics and
douchebags actual literal dude.
Apparently I'm a lot.
There's people that will take a Epsom
salts and they drink it in a glass,
like a couple tablespoons.
Does that go through you like rocket fuel?
That's what I've heard. I've heard
it's just really uncomfortable. Gassy,
uncomfortable, very diuretic.
Don't rely on that either.
But is it to have a benefit?
Is there something to clean
your shit hole out? Yeah,
I mean if you're doing a
cleanse right and you need to,
you need to open up the channels.
Have you talked to be doing a cleanse
is chances are you're a douchebag if
you're one of those fucking
guys and cleansing, cleansing.
I'm getting very feminine cleansing.
Yeah.
But if you are doing some kind of fast
or some kind of protocol where you are
trying to detoxify your body, it's good
to open up the channels of elimination.
One of the channels of elimination is
shit. Right? So it's good to actually,
cause you will get kind of constipated
because you're not feeding your body with
a bunch of food.
So it's good to actually push that out.
But usually better than Epsom salt
is going to be oxygenated magnesium.
There's a couple of brands like mango
seven, um, and that ozonated magnesium.
There's a couple of different types,
but it'll actually help really push
that through with a kind of a good,
does the absence salts contain
magnesium? It does, right?
Maybe that is the mechanism perhaps you
thought to, yeah, because different form,
one of the benefits of the tank is that
you absorb Epson salts or your skin.
So the fact that you don't have
a tank I'm going to, right.
We've got to get you on that shit.
That's correct. At this point.
That's preposterous. A
great, uh, magnesiums like
the thing that we all need,
what we, none of us really get
enough of. Yeah. Magnesium,
zinc and magnesium. Yeah. A little
lot of minerals. Actually. The,
remember that guy that was around dead
doctors don't lie. And he was, uh,
explaining like cheerleaded minerals and
he was saying that mineral deficiencies,
the reason for like all these issues in
farm animals that we fixed a long time
ago, cause we just give the mineral rich
diets and we add minerals to their food.
But we don't add, I'll add minerals to
people's food. He's like, do you know,
few people take mineral supplements?
And he was like talking about
all these different deficiencies,
calcium treating osteoporosis.
And it was pretty fucking crazy shit
convincing because there's not
as much mineral in the soil.
I mean they're replanting over
and over again in the same fields.
And that's where I, vegetables are
coming from constantly replanting.
So the minerals in the soil
are mostly from the fertilizer.
What they're actually putting in,
well,
they're not necessarily
putting in complete full
spectrum balanced minerals back
in the soil.
So the,
a lot of the food we eat don't have the
mineral content that we originally had
if you were farming in a
really sustainable way and
rotating around getting new
soil and things like that solution.
Now easiest one is the Himalayan salt,
84 trace minerals right there and
the salt. And that's, you know,
one of the reasons why salt was so prized
back in ancient times is that that's
the best source for your mineral.
The easiest source at least.
There's a lot of good sources,
but this is a really good reason to
forgetting Himalayan salt, right?
Because that's like it's salt that hasn't
reached any, there's been no pollution,
I'd say.
Yeah,
it's like a hundred million years old.
So all of the pollution that's in the
world now, everything that's in the air,
everything that's in the water and the
fish and all that shit that wasn't around
back a hundred million years ago.
Just Tara doctorals and some ancestors
roaming around on the ground.
So there was nothing to pollute the salt
at all. No oil spills, none of that.
So it's a very pristine deposit.
That's fine.
You put like a little in your water in
the morning. Yeah, I do it intermittently.
I actually like it at night and I was,
I had a pretty dramatic incident where I,
for like a week I started going through,
I was uh,
I was taking very demineralized water,
like highly filtered water just
cause it's a water filter that out.
So then I was starting to hear my pulse
in my ears when I would go to sleep and
I was having trouble
sleeping and they're like,
well it could be a mineral deficiency
for your adrenal glands. And I was like,
okay. He's like, yeah, they're like, take
a bunch of salt before you go to bed,
Himalayan salt before you go to bed.
I did that and made a dramatic difference.
So now for me,
I take more salt at night before I go
to bed and I sleep a lot better and I
don't get that. It wasn't
so much that I was, it just,
I could hear my pulse in my yeah,
years and I felt like a real deficiency.
What would cause that? Did they explain
the mechanism has a mineral deficiency.
The adrenal glands need,
you know,
need the minerals to
function at an optimal level.
Like most of the systems in our body.
So all kinds of systems need the minerals.
Minerals are kind of the
foundation of what makes us up,
makes everything run really well.
So were you drinking distilled water?
Is that what highly highly
distilled water Kangen water,
it's called Kangen water.
It's just happened to the filter.
Completely mineral devoid
water at my house, you know,
and I was eating good
vegetables and stuff,
but the vegetables don't have
all of those minerals. And I was,
I would occasionally
sprinkle salt on my food,
but I wasn't really paying attention
to my salt intake, you know?
And then I tried to regiment
it and actually supplementally
take it and it made
a huge impact for me. Wow. Yeah. Cause
you have to be careful with that.
I mean all these water systems,
I mean this is a fancy water system.
I'm not endorsing it by any means.
It's just good to take everything out.
But it takes too much out.
You have absolutely no minerals and
electrolytes in your water if you're using
one of these highly filtered system.
So adding a pinch of that salt back in
is going to be important because that's
your body runs on. That's interesting
too. But what about like, um, springwater?
Is that the best water to get a new body?
Like there's a difference between spring
water and like what is the difference
between a spring one and
like Disani and all those,
like those are filtered waters,
right? Right. So that's,
they're basically taking
water from anywhere.
It can be as dirty as can be and
they're just running it through adequate
filters to take the bad shit out of it.
And that's distilled,
that's filtered water.
Now springwater is actually
filtered either through the ground,
which is the best way to do it.
Like a volcanic system where the water
naturally filters to the lava that comes
out.
And that's going to collect all the
minerals through the earth that you really
need. And that's going to be
the best way to do it. Yeah.
My friend's place in Colorado has
a a, well yeah, and she gets it.
She gets it like right from the, well,
it's incredible. It's like spring water.
Totally.
So like you've free springwater,
so you probably need half the Himalayan
salt or a quarter or maybe you don't
need any,
I don't even know how rich that water is,
but you'll need way less than if you're
constantly drinking filtered distilled
water. Yeah. They pull water
right out of the fucking ground
up there, man. It's nuts. I mean that's
where they're getting their water.
They're getting free springwater,
just pulling it out of the ground just
like drank tragic. I get some water here.
Yeah. You know, try it. Should I
go into studio city? Dig it up.
Fuck at a hole in the ground and Fido,
not going to be good.
Suck it out with a straw.
You're dead.
Even some places out in the hill country
in Texas we have wells and you bring it
out. It smells like eggs, software.
So there's no way you're going to
stomach drinking that that's so nasty.
And Himalayan salt that you have
on on it.com is to prove too.
So it's what she proved. You proved.
What does that mean? Oh Shit, baby. Oh,
it's kosher. Is that what they
call it? Proved to me make that up.
I think a rabbi has to bless it.
Do it a little bit. Well, no,
I think and not punch parameters like
not like you can't like rub his balls on
it, you know, none of that.
Yeah, it definitely not.
He has to know that the process
has been observed. Yeah.
Do you have like real strict rules?
I think like what's slaughtering animals
especially. Yeah, very specific rules.
But what's kosher and what's not, but you
know it's not kosher bacon, so kosher.
Stupid. Okay. That's
ridiculous. Okay. If you don't,
if you don't like Bacon,
you can go fuck yourself for real.
I was thinking about that and I kind of
feel like the Jews are pretty cool with
masturbation.
I'm pretty cool with sex.
I feel like they had to pick
something that they get.
They get outlawed and say foot beading
and they were just, they got bacon.
We could live without that
shit. Well, jerk off all day.
We'll fuck whoever we want, but
bacon, we're going to outlaw that.
So people take our religion seriously
and dirty salt you think and how much
tricker gnosis pigs have pigs.
The thing about pigs is that there's,
they're omnivores and they,
they're oftentimes are scavengers,
so they'll eat like wormy food man.
And you can get all kinds of horrible
diseases if you don't cook their meat.
Yeah.
So I'm sure back when they did a shitty
job of cooking meat and they didn't know
what the fuck worms where they would
eat that stuff and get really sick and
possibly even die. Bacon back then was
like rod dog or go in Africa. Yeah.
I mean dangerous pigs would just
be one going at your own risk.
But it's tempting, you know,
because it's delicious. Yeah.
They didn't know what the fuck they were
doing and those pigs are wild to just
eat and fucking cadavers and shit
and yeah. But wild pigs are dirty.
Franks getting rid of evidence.
Yeah. Like that movie snatch. Right.
We talked about that. Uh, this
is not even a commercial anymore,
but then install goes Himalayan
salt. Yeah. Go get some, uh,
if you haven't been to
the fitness section on it,
we got pretty much anything you need
for a serious rigorous strength and
conditioning program.
We provide it all when you talk
about stuff for functional strength,
weight vests, battle ropes, kettlebells,
steel maces and steel clubs,
both of them,
which are,
they're excellent for developing like
all full body movement and the kind of
strength that you could really translate
into any athletic endeavor or murder.
While if you know,
I really slow shot the Steel Steel Mason,
the club and you're a really strong,
uh, we, we also have jump ropes
now, pull up bar, wall medicine,
full home gym and you know, and
really are functional stuff. Yeah.
And two of the best DVDs we eventually,
we'll make our own DVD.
We promise you this, we
promise you this. But for now,
the extreme Kettlebell,
a cardio DVD one and two by
the fabulous keep Keith Weber,
it's tough to keep those
fucking things in office, right?
We actually took over production.
So we've got us covered.
You can hammer us with us things
now we're not waiting for oh, Keith.
And they send them to us.
He finally worked it out,
right? Yeah, we worked it out.
Is it possible to get those DVDs about
was it was international incident every
time we had to try and get
them. Hope you're happy, Keith.
Keith, I hope he's happy.
He's happy. He deserves it. That
is a bad ass workout. Both of them,
they're ruthless. So if you, if you've
never done any kettle bells before,
really our urge you to start slow,
start slow.
And if you can hire a trainer to someone
who's Kettlebell certified to just go
over the movements with you, you can
work out at home, you can totally get,
I do kettle bell workouts
at home all the time,
but the first couple of
times you're doing it,
it would be really smart if you're paid.
Very close attention to technique and
very close attention to your form and make
sure you don't hurt yourself. We don't
want you hurting yourself. Generally.
We have a bunch of videos
from the a I KFF, which is one of our
really cool new partners. They're, uh,
one of the biggest sanctioning bodies
for Kettlebell sport here in the u s and
two of their top athletes are
on there on the side as well.
Given some instructional tips.
If you try to find that on Youtube
Penny stock or you can go to, um,
you should be able to navigate to
it from the kettle bells themselves,
not the DVD. But if you go to the youtube
page you can definitely check that out.
And um,
Ken Blackburn,
Mitch Blackburn Rather Than Sun Mitch
is like 165 pounds and set the American
record for the um,
the clean impress double clean and
press was 72 pounds. Yeah, each cattle,
he did it like 65 times in 10 minutes
without putting them down. Oh,
bolts on that. He's like
165 pounds, 19 year old kid.
You can see him on the honor roll.
Actually, if you look up Mitch blackboard,
that's somebody, it just shows you what
it is. I mean, and it's form these guys,
their form is impeccable. You have,
they're not wasting any energy at all.
It was cool to watch them.
Cool to learn from him.
You know what's really fascinating about
a lot of these guys just they don't
look like,
they're not like bodybuilder looking guys.
It's like they have this incredible
strength for the amount of mass that they
carry around. Like you were saying,
this guy is 160 pounds, 165 pounds.
Jesus Christ. That's a tiny little
fella. There's the guy, right?
The fact that the guy that weighs 160
fucking pounds can throw two 72 pound
kettle bells around like that.
He was ripping the 90s up and
snatch in the 90s saying whatever.
That's an insane, oh good. What
do you want me to do? Okay,
you've got some shock hair.
I don't know.
Like for the average
folk like you would have,
you would struggle with a 35 pounder.
Trust me,
it's hard the first time you do it, it's
real awkward. But what did develops,
I am a fucking huge proponent
of kettlebells. Kettlebells.
It would, it would,
it gives me is like real
functional strength,
functional strength that just
directly translates to Jujitsu.
I noticed a big difference in my
rolling when I got really heavy with
kettlebells. Yup. Because it
transferred my workouts from,
oh today I'm going to bench, uh, tomorrow
we're going to do squats and all that.
That gets you stronger.
But there was something different about
doing it all together when you were
doing like,
you know like alternating cleans and clean
press squats and he's crazy full body
exercises. It's like you didn't just
get stronger, you also got more fit.
You'll also got like more endurance.
You also got like
translatable explosive energy.
Some of those other main
lifts like bench and squat,
they're really good for getting
you bigger in particular, you know,
and stronger in certain finite ways.
But if you're talking about
general functional strength,
Kettle Bell is the clubs,
the battle ropes, yeses.
That's really going to get
you to get the job done
and it gives you a balanced strength.
And look, if you want to get crazy,
I mean like a lot of people, like there's
dudes that can squat 225 pounds easy.
Like,
I've met a lot of guys who can do that,
but how many guys could do that
with two 120 pound kettle bells,
right? You mean tell me.
You really can do that.
You can clean and squat 220 pound
catapults. You probably can't.
You know you're going to wobble
all over the place. You're,
you're dealing with this weird thing
that you have to kind of control them
balanced with. He got to learn how to
hold on to them correctly. You got a bill,
this weird kind of functional strength.
We are swinging these fucking cannon
balls around and touching them on your
forearm without snapping your
arm. Yeah, it's manly shit. Folks,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com o. N N. I t.
Use a codename Brogan and you will
save 10% off any and all supplements.
Did Somebody Fart? Seriously? I didn't
any natural dick pills coming soon.
That was bad.
My old business, you know,
the natural, the Dick Pills,
we have those rock hard weekends,
but we found out that the whole
game and a lot of those pills is,
you just sneak a little Viagra in it and
then you get popped and then you sneak
a little Cialis in it and then you get
popped and then your third version is
just pretty garbage. Right? I mean,
once you get used to the paradigm of
what those drugs can do, just forget it.
I mean, you can take all the herbs you
want and it's not going to really move the
needle, so to speak. But you know, I mean,
you can help support the systems
in general, like with t plus.
But as far as dick pills themselves,
forget it synthesizes a fucking joke
doesn't even exist. So there's no
like aunt boners or anything that you
could put in there that just natural
calling Ian boners is just by Agra Bro.
It's, yeah. And a lot of them,
one's in the gas station actually work
because they're putting like Chinese
viagara and then, yeah. So
it's like you'd think there,
they're a real piece of shit.
But you look at some terrible label on
the gas station. It's like, I don't know,
phaser laser hard five. And you're like,
what the hell is that? But if you take it,
it's like a little bit of
Chinese viagara ridiculous.
He's so ridiculous. Like why wouldn't
you take the real critical drug? Well,
you know what it is just like,
let's just hope this one works because
some are more powerful than others in
anthrax.
So you like lose all responsibility for
what happens based on the luck of the
draw. It's kind of like
a job, but there's,
I've found a couple of them that like
you really take and it's the most,
you're just boner, but oh, that's
hilarious. But it's last seven days. Well,
I'm, it's the Cialis one. Hey listen,
don't die. Please don't die. Uh,
on a.com o n n I t use code name Brogue
and save yourself 10% off any and all
supplements.
Brian
experience,
but hey, you never know
until you try, you know?
Yeah, exactly. This mother Fucker, when
this Dick Pills, you believe this guy,
I took two different brands last week.
Why not?
You would doctor and tell
him your dick is bro,
he will give you amazing drugs.
I'm not saying that it's broken,
but don't tell the doctorates broken.
Did they have a test though?
Like does he rubbing it and go like,
you're lying sucks your
cock for five minutes.
And if you can think of dead
puppies for five minutes,
then he'll give you the pills. They
can't say no can they? There's no,
there's no way for them to test the horse.
They can't.
They don't want to stimulate your
prostate with a large finger death grip.
And then if you get hard,
they,
they can't obviously. I mean, did you use,
they're going to take your word for it.
Why would you say that? You can't get
hard. If you could get hard. Well,
you wouldn't lie about
that. What'd Ya, they don't,
nobody breaks their Dick with that stuff.
Do they?
Can you possibly like
break it so that you like,
you can't get a boner without it.
You know how like some dudes,
they get addicted to
those sign the sprays.
The biggest problem is a
psychological addiction. You know,
like the back when we were selling the
rock hard that worked back at flashlight
because it had flaggers yeah. Alison and
or whatever it had it. And I don't know.
Um, but back when it worked, there was
people who would take it and they'd get,
you know, they start
off with a girl, right?
And they'd be hooking up with a
girl and they were like, oh my God,
you're a god among men.
And then they'd get that.
And then if they didn't have it,
you know,
they would start to panic and then
their brain would start to take action.
Is the brain gets activated
in the sexual act.
Isn't it crazy how different you can
get excited for one girl over another?
Like there are some girls and we all know
them in your life where when you're around
them, it's just like instant flagpole.
And then there's other
girls where it's just,
it just for whatever reason
they can look just as pretty,
they can be just as nice.
They can be just as attractive.
But this is some freak connection you
have with thinkers and people really do
think so. Yeah, I think so. I think
really what you're saying is kind of true.
Like the juice essence is you have
Zam Zam Isru how's you say that?
That French dip. How's you,
I never knew how to say that.
They don't to that the restaurant.
I know it on the other way where they've
had like guys sleep in the same shirt
for,
you know,
a few weeks or whatever and then they
have gross smell the shirts and they'll be
very attracted to one shirt and
completely repulsed by another shirt.
Just by smelling the actual pheromones
in it. I would lose that one for sure.
I fucking stink going down.
I eat too much meat. It's all coming
out of my pores and shit. I don't know.
I've smelled some of my clothes. My, uh,
g the worst is Jujitsu
because he take your, you,
you sweat so much and then you take your
shit off and you throw it in your gym
bag and then you throw your gym bag in
the trunk where it cooks cause it's 110
degrees in La. So you're driving
around with your gym bag,
cooking in the trunk and then you pop
that bitch open and unzip it and it's just
like ammonia and funk and,
and that's where it,
there's a lot of skin diseases that
people get from that stuff because they
don't wash those things
enough and you're essentially,
you're rolling around and
microbes and bacteria and shit.
And the worst part is not when it's fresh,
like fresh sweat is not that bad.
Same as fresh urine. You can drink
your own fresh urine all the time,
but you're leaving me.
I know,
but if you leave a cup of that
year and out for a day or so,
don't fucking drink that.
That's poison.
It's like a breeding ground for further
back to same with your gym clothes.
I would agree that it's sound
advice. Don't drink, drink.
I think I'm going to ship into a
meme. That's the next meal. You,
Uncle Aubrey says don't drink old pis
here it on it. We don't recommend
drinking your own when it's old.
So I'm thinking of trying to do an am
Anita Mascara experience and I'm thinking
I'm going to eat it and then drink
my piss and see what's up. Yeah,
that's what you're supposed to do. I
would say no. I said, well, I'll do it.
I'll do it once and then I got to try it.
I've tried everything else for real folks.
This isn't a shamanically tradition.
I know you're listening
to this and you're like,
there's no way these guys are serious.
No. The true shamonic tradition is,
it was explained to me, um, by uh,
this Guy Jack Herer and he
said that the idea is that you,
you eat the, the drug, the plant
mush. I'm an eater. Miscarriage.
It's a very different,
it's not psilocybin,
it's some other type of what
you're shooting for is Musk, Amal.
You should, the active compound
is Musk, Amal and what its Axon,
a very different mechanism action.
So the mechanism of action
of emoney to miscarry,
it actually acts as a Gaba agonist,
so it's going to give you more of the
neurotransmitter Gaba where it's still the
[inaudible] the mechanism of
action that there recently finding,
which I learned a lot about
at the maps conferences,
mechanism of action of Siliciden is it's
actually restricting blood flow to your
default mode network,
part of your brain,
which is your top down control mechanism
in your brain so that you're basically
your mental cerebral filter that allows
you to focus on the day to day mundane
tasks starts to go to sleep and that
happens to be the center that controls
depression and a bunch of other things,
which is why the clinical application is
proving so important and impressive and
and all these people, but that's a
totally different mechanism of action.
Then the Amanita miscarried,
which is basically flooding your brain
with more Gabba from what I understand,
but the Musk,
Amal is a tricky beast and it doesn't
necessarily come out through your gut.
However, once it gets processed
through your kidneys and you piss it,
it can be passed up to five times.
They say through different people.
So like I could Piss,
oh, you could drink it, you
could piss give it to Brian.
He could pick it and then Brian could
give it to two other people and everybody
will be high as fuck. Wow. That's
what they say. How would they know?
How would they know? Why would they find
out? What are we doing with our lives?
Which sitting around drinking
each other's pice to get high.
What are you seeing in fairies?
Cock sucker watching Pluto.
He's supposed to be kind of like a
little bit drunk and a little bit like a
little bit high,
like a psychedelic.
I only had one experience and it didn't
work. You didn't drink your own piss.
You got to commit. You've gotta go
in. You can't just put the tip in.
You gotta go miles deep.
Huh? Is that how it works?
You're supposed to just eat it and then
drink your own piston and that's what
gets you high.
I mean
there's some ways that I think you
can heat it and like lightly bake it.
I don't know.
But I think the sure fire way if you
really want to commit is to eat it.
Then drink your piss and then you can,
you know,
but you feel so stupid. If it's
getting worse. That's true.
Sitting there with piss mouth,
not high.
I'm just thinking what kind of a losing
him. I should just become a republican.
Okay. I should just go the other way and
get single malt scotch and sneaking some
Cuban cigars and just become an
asshole or renting a movie while I'm,
but if it works it around eating mushrooms
and drinking piss the fuck am I doing
with my life.
You got a dirty garage like I was
going to get to that but I had to eat
mushrooms and drink my own piss first.
I'm a fucking real winter over here.
I'm going to film it for,
for all of the savages cause it
is perfectly legal in the US.
Seminated Mascara is not
a scheduled substance,
so the reward if it
works and it was awesome.
It was pretty cool because we
actually have something legal to do.
Yeah, and you're just going to encourage
people to do that. No, I don't. I'm not.
Look, please let me be
the pig here. I don't
know. It could be terrible,
but I'll let you know.
You have to give one estate if it's bad.
Also you have to have a [inaudible].
There's just like all with pissy mouth.
Self paid feeling the lowest of the low.
I've never met anyone,
but he's had a good one. Is it a good a
amnesia, miscarry or experience or not?
Not. Not that I can remember
anybody telling me about one.
They've always said like, oh,
it didn't work for me. Yeah,
I met somebody who had a weird
one and a not so good one
drink,
pee bro.
Weird and not so good, but there
is piss drinking. So come on,
join the party. That's a tradition around
it though, you know? I don't mean that.
We can all check each other's pissed by.
Come on over here.
He's got it all figured out.
You just got to get a fresh is in to
you and then you piss him. No, no, no.
See that's not how it's done. I forgot to
bring cups. We all thought how it works.
I just pissing your mouth and
is that what we do with you?
That's straight from the spout kind of
Potty we doing here the freshest way to
get this in his ass mouth.
We're going to work this out.
We're going to get high
as fuck disappeared.
It is exactly what
he's trying to trick us in.
You stumble upon this fucking party.
You open up the tent door.
What the fuck's Piss all over the
place. Bunch of guys. The Kochs names.
We just trying to get enlightenment
but imagine if it does work and you get
someone really high and they love it
and then you could trick them constantly
cause my piss.
You just get a drink
it yet here. That would pissed them off.
One. It tastes like total primary care.
Maybe some tea.
Plus did you pack it like a musket?
Why is Doctor Laser wearing lipstick?
We need to call doctor laser and ask him
how many of those books behind him he's
red cause it's driving us crazy.
Yeah.
I picture a doctor Lacey's get those old
school books and nobody really reads.
Yeah,
he's old and he's read them.
I don't know the best way to answer.
That's the best way it is.
The finished that say, I don't know.
I don't know. But he does have have
the brain surgery kit from
Napoleon's fuel doctor.
Pretty cool shots in his office.
Yeah.
They had a brain surgery big saw like it
looks more like woodworking equipment,
but like really finely crafted
made woodworking equipment,
things that like crack things,
things that saw things. Oh my God.
He debts and he actually uses it.
Basically he has his patients walked by
it and if they get queasy and they can't
handle it, he's like, no, you're
not the person for me. Cause he's a,
he's a tinkerer.
I mean he's going to go in there and
actually cut your head and do some work.
That's what his specialty is.
He's done like 3000 open skulls or
surgeries or something like that.
Oh yeah, he's in it. He's no
gee, he's cool. Holy Shit.
You imagine working at 3000 brains.
Yeah.
What an power that
must be to those guys like that they,
they can fix someone's brain.
You know, I kind of agree.
Kind of out your cancer and fix your brain
and then send you back to how it live.
A healthy life.
Yup.
And he did it. I met one of the guys
that he did that for. This guy, uh,
is one of his patients and it's
pretty remarkable. Went through there,
did the brain surgery and then from,
and that's actually how I met Dr
[inaudible]. He did the brain surgery.
Then he took a bunch of the ingredients.
We have an Alpha brain too,
and he recovered like way fast.
This is of course just one story,
but he recovered super fast and that turn
Dr Lasar onto the potential for these
herbs to work in conjunction with
what he was doing on the brain.
So that's how we kinda got got hooked up.
That's interesting. Did, did he ever
talk to um, a Roman [inaudible]?
No, he hasn't, but we talked
about that a little bit.
I think it's actually in
the long interview that we
have up there. But um, yeah,
the uh, the brain damage issue
is pretty, it's pretty serious.
I don't think he's ever been
hooked up with bill though.
Yeah. Well Roman Ascii, that's
why he created that neuro one.
That was the first nootropic that
I had heard of. We were on um, um,
no name and no name and Alice or Alison?
No named Sarah and Nunu Sarah.
No name rather on Alice
radio. Yeah. Anyway. Um,
and a no name African.
His real name.
I always called them no names. How weird
is that? It's top cool guy. Anyway,
he was training with Bill Roman house
key and Bill Romanowski got them to start
eating healthy and started giving him
this neuro one shit. Well this is this a,
it was like,
it's a nootropic but it's also got
like a little bit of caffeine in it.
It's pretty interesting stuff and he
developed it because of concussions. Yeah,
makes sense.
You've got to feed,
feed back the brain when it's been
deprived from getting swollen,
swollen and pushed up against your skull.
It was had a good program.
I was at a, a a neurological
research center today and uh,
one of the things that these people
were telling me why they were there,
I was there for this silly TV show.
But there's people that take their
kids there. Like if the kids are uh,
involved in football and then football
injuries and they're talking about it
like these kids don't like 15,
16 years old and they just have these
massive concussions and the father's like,
well when can you get back in there?
And the mother is like,
is he going to be okay?
Right.
The mothers are concerned that their
kid is getting really badly hurt and the
fathers are, they want him to get
back in there. It's weird. She's she,
she was describing it to me like you
know these situations that she's dealing
with with these fathers and
these kids and she's like,
it's really creepy cause these kids
don't know any better and they're just
running their dads and like want them
to get back in there like they get can
cost.
Like do you understand what that is?
Do you understand what getting
shut off is running on each other,
colliding hands.
Do you know whoa
man and the brain, there's so much
more we still have to learn about it.
Did you happen to see that thing
on 60 minutes? Where there,
there are people who are now able to
control prosthetic limbs with their
thoughts alone and did you see that?
So basically they hook up these,
they hook up these arms.
Now the first,
the first version prototype was they
hooked the arms up and they actually
hardwire it somehow into the nerves.
But it's still their
thoughts that can allow them,
like they can shake hands with people
just from like their brain telling this
completely prosthetic arm to
shake hands or like grab a ball.
They can tell if a ball is hard or a
telephone ball is soft just from feedback.
It's bilateral. So it's not only they're
squeezing but their fingers can give, uh,
signals to their brain and let him know
if what they're squeezing as hard or
soft.
So it goes both ways.
And then they figured out how to hook it
up wirelessly so that they can actually
control arms that are not even on them.
And they can make those arms
move just with their thoughts.
So [inaudible] was on 60 minutes, like
a week ago. I was fucking blown away.
So like an Avatar type
thing? Totally. Well not,
but the first steps,
like the big baby steps
towards doing it with Wifi.
Yeah. I mean I was, what
is that? You remember that?
It's the old experiments where they pretty
much did, let me see. Oh, those rush. Oh,
don't show me this. The dog
had won. That shit ain't cool.
I don't even know if that's
real. Is that real? It's real.
I don't want the Russians.
It was a cool segment on, uh,
on 60 minutes that it's literally like
probably two weeks ago. Wow, that's,
that's fucking freaky. Pretty. I the,
the crazy part to me was
the fact that they could,
it was giving him signals back from
their fingers to their brain. That was,
that was what really blew my, I mean,
I guess the whole thing, did you know,
just the fact that you think of this brain
and thoughts is this kind of nebulous
thing, but it's actually, it is a signal.
There is some kind of electrical signal
that they can get a machine program,
a machine to receive and
respond based upon a thought,
a willful action to do something.
It can pick that up.
I don't know how the hell that happens
and imagine if they can do that now.
Imagine what a thousand years
from now it's holiday. Yeah.
Probably will be able to just lie in bed
and send our robot out to do everything
we needed to do. Drive the car, you know,
and we look through its eyes as it
drives the car. We looked through,
it says eyes as it goes
to the supermarket,
picks up groceries and we're just
sitting at home, beaten off, beaten off,
pretending with this person and the
robot wanders through the fucking town.
Does all your tasks come back home and
you never leave the house? Yeah. Yeah.
But imagine and then the
application for sports,
there's been a couple of movies like that,
but you could go full.
Let's say you created this kind of
android creature that you can control with
your mind.
You could go full gladiator style with
net and tried to sort and just have the
most brutal. Obviously it'd be expensive
because machines are expensive, whatever.
But that'd be sweet. That'd be crazy.
Bumper cars with a Ferrari. That's true.
But you want to just take your fucking
robot body torture people with it.
Yeah, no, don't do that.
But I bet you know what they
would do. You know like
people play the sims. Yeah,
I bet they would play like a
real live version of the sims.
Just let their human body go out there
and interact with all these other robot
bodies. You know, they
take their body, they uh,
they lie down and they look through the
body or look through the eyes of this
thing and then send it off.
Like it's a little game and you send your
robot out and the robot goes and fucks
other robots and parties and your robots
and animal and he drinks and drives.
Cause he doesn't even
live in the real world.
He lives in this fucking crazy robot.
Why don't we realize that's
what's already happening?
Where is the robot has
turned us in and do a robot?
I keep on thinking simulation
theory at the shit. Like,
like your inner voice is
actually you in the future.
Like talking to yourself or
something like that. Hit me. Right.
I think, I think everybody knows,
especially when you're impulsive, fuck.
Like I know you are and I
am and you've been to sun.
We all been a little bit
impulsive and there's always,
when you're about to do something
and there's a voice, it goes,
don't fucking do it,
dude.
You gotta listen to that voice always.
That voice is always right.
You know, there's like a
weird rush on the other side
too that tells you not to do it.
Like it's kind of feel good.
You know,
like when you're about to like if you're
about to yell at somebody and you know
you shouldn't do that,
there's pretty much no reason everything.
Yeah,
you're right.
But when you get this kind of like energy
that comes up and it feels like it's
going to be good to release it.
Yup. What the fuck is that? Oh,
that's you protecting yourself.
Well, why does it feel good though?
It feels good because sometimes people
need to be shown that their cons,
an evolutionary response. The
only way people learn, um,
how to behave is by feedback.
The way they learn how to be harmonious
with their fellow brothers and sisters
of the world.
It's by feedback and when you're not good
at it and you get bad feedback all the
time and you don't adjust,
that's like a sign of mental
illness or stupidity or a,
a lack of education or lack of someone
explaining or your own personal critical
thinking involving the way the
world works. But for most people,
as you get older,
you get way better at communicating
because you've gone through this feedback
loop several times and he sorta stabilize
it and you know what people like and
what they don't like and you know how
to get things off on the right foot and
how not to, and it's like sort
of easier to navigate. And
he, there is, as you know,
the key there is not to become completely
enslaved by the feelings and thoughts
and the kind of world around you and so
that you're constantly living to please
what the Toltecs would call
it, the dream, you know,
the cocreated world around you.
So yes, don't be a Dick, you know,
learn not to hurt people.
But then at the same time,
don't judge yourself according to all of
these opinions that are generally wrong
anyways. People don't necessarily always
want you to be your best, you know,
so you gotta find your inner path as well.
Adjust
to guiding principle.
It's a real problem for young people
when they're dealing with haters,
like the first haters in their life.
You know,
like it could be someone who's at work
with you or someone you go on to school
with or whatever,
but it might be like the first time you
like for someone like actively hates on
you and that should can affect you.
And I always say that it's like
snake venom and that like Kevin,
a little bit of Haider is like good
cause you know how to deal with it.
And then when, when you get a full
blast of it, you're like, bitch,
I'm immune to that stupid
shit. And they're like, you've
been bitten a few times.
You understand it. Because people who
don't have never been hated on before,
like you see them get hated on,
they're like, oh my goodness.
Just that wave of negativity that can
erupt at any time on the Internet.
That absolutely. I mean, you
know, I felt that the first time,
obviously in sports or whatever,
you get these mild detractors,
but you can always kind of see him.
But then as soon as I stepped into
the public eye, a lot of support,
a lot of amazing people I've met and
then a contingency of people who hate me
just despise me. And I was
looking at him like, why?
What is the reason?
Like I couldn't properly deal with it.
I think I had to talk to many people I
could and just kind of started a house.
There's some people that are just
going to be negative no matter what.
But there's also,
it's fucked up thing,
but there's a truth in that. It's
good to get your ass kicked. Yeah.
And it's good to get your ass
kicked on by the Internet too.
It's good.
You know it,
it doesn't seem like it's good when it's
happening and it might be completely
off base,
but if it's right even a little bit,
they're doing you a service
because they're pointing
out holes and you're tying
up your game. Yeah. The pointing out
holes in your game and it might be,
it might be fair, but in nine might not
be fair to you got to deal with that too.
But that's part of the
game that's part of you.
And eventually,
hopefully we all hope for some form of
personal sovereignty where no matter what
anybody says about you or
how anybody describes you,
it's better way of putting it. You know
who you are. I know you're all right.
And like all they're doing is exposing
this need to detract from another person,
just need to diminish another person.
And she's a massive weakness. It is.
And you know, along and we've
all been guilty of, uh, for
sure. And along with that,
it's also learning to take the praise.
Not too seriously. Yes. You know,
you can't get your tires last humped up
and really buy into that whole thing and
that'll lead you down a stray weird
path of ego and feeding off that kind of
energy that's no good either,
either to tractors or too much praise.
Just appreciate it for what it is,
but really judge yourself by your
own criteria. Criteria, you know,
you know only you know
really if you did your best,
if you put out the maximum effort to
try and achieve the result, and I only,
you should be able to judge
yourself toe. Yeah. Well if you're,
if you're really objective and
that's what we should all strive for.
Writing like real objectivity.
If he could really just fucking really
look at what you're doing right or wrong
and what you're enjoying about your life,
what you're not,
kind of get that bitch back on track
sometimes it's hard to see yourself there,
has to see other people,
which is why a lot of the most fucked
up people with the most fucked up lives
always want to give you advice.
Yeah.
I could wants to give you more advice
than someone whose life is a mess.
You know what you gotta do,
man.
You've got to get together with your girl
and you've got to work this out. Okay.
I know you don't want to work this out,
but you've got to work and you're like,
you really given advice on relationships.
You crazy fuck head.
They say that most of the people who get
degrees in psychology are the ones who
are trying to work out their own
problems that most vehemently. I mean,
I don't know, that's just
hearsay, but that's, yeah. Yeah.
I would think of psychologists would
do the word of shit when they beat up.
You know what I mean? Things.
What is it? What is a sexual, uh,
like one of those people
that's like a sexual counselor.
What did they beat it off to? You
know, do they be constantly analyzing?
It can't be that much fun. Yeah. Right.
Like how do they really totally cut loose.
You're constantly thinking about
whether or not she did as good.
Up to objectivity is a real challenge.
And I think one of the tools
that both me and you have found,
I've been different ways to break through
that kind of mental patterning that
gets you in trouble.
So the tank is a great way to do it.
And there's different meditation
techniques that are great ways,
but sometimes for us to really fix gold
monkeys like myself and you and some
other people when we just need
something heavier to do it.
And I think that's when,
you know,
I've gone to Peru and done
the Iowasca or you can go,
so hopefully somewhere safe and do a
heavy psilocybin trip or find some way to
actually get that part of your
mind to really be objective,
to kind of cut out all the bullshit and
look at yourself with a true reflection.
Yeah. And I feel like there's certain
doors that get open when you have those
experiences and when those doors get open,
it's like the whole world
just takes a turn to the left.
Like it's just not the same world
anymore. Yeah. It's just not.
And that's scary for a lot of people.
Mad and it makes sense,
but you got to really
look at it objectively.
And one of the things
you got to look at is
do you really like the world
the way it is? I really scared.
And taking a left turn into crazyville
crazy film might not be that bad.
Trust me,
the regular world is crazy enough.
Take a little trip down the Leprechaun
lane and have a chat with the pixies and
the other dimensions.
It's not a bad idea.
You got to know what the fuck is
going on with your brain though.
That's the problem. I would never
tell anybody to do mushrooms or acid.
And even though I have, I would never
tell anybody to do any. Now today,
knowing what I know would
never tell anybody to do any
psychedelic cause I don't
know how the fuck their brain works.
And then, so having an in something,
I always kind of reiterate,
having a really good guide is important.
Someone who can not only ask you
questions but kind of look you in the eye,
analyze, um, what you should
or should not do. I mean,
even the shamans down in Peru,
part of the ceremony is
before you get the Iowasca,
they kind of get a sense of you,
even if you can't speak the language,
but they get a sense of being, you
can sense crazy. You know, like,
especially they're highly tuned to do
that and they look at you and how's it
going? Why some people get like
a really little tiny, you know,
third of a cup and then
they go on their way.
Because that's all that the Shamans,
no, that's all they can handle.
That's all they're in for. And
then other people, you know,
they'll fill that bitch
to the brim and bid.
I'll come back for more if you want it.
That thick,
thick,
Brown bittery fiery
Iowasca into your stomach.
And you know what, I've never understood
about the IOWASCA thing. I must say.
I'm going to have to do, I'll ask
it to learn this, the tobacco thing,
like what is it about the,
is blowing tobacco smoke that
activates some of the helices surgeons.
I think it has to do with your actually
your nicotinic receptors in your brain
there. So there's something, you know,
the DMT, the tryptamine like a stack,
like you're stacking,
that's these receptors.
And this is swimming a little
deeper than I probably can go,
but I think it has something, you know,
nicotine acts on certain mental receptors.
Um, I think it's your nicotinic receptors
and then tryptamine acts on certain
receptors and somehow there is a,
there is a synergy there.
I haven't necessarily experienced that,
but what I did experience,
which was really weird,
I have no very good explanation for this,
but at the end of one particular ceremony,
he smoked the tobacco.
The chairman smoked the tobacco Rustica
which is different than the tobacco that
we smoke. It's a different
species of plant entirely.
So Tobacco Rustica they smoked a big hand
rolled cigarette from that and he like
blew the smoke all over my body. I didn't
feel anything at the moment. I was like,
okay well I'm going to smell like
this burnt plant. Cool. That's good.
But he really like took care and put
it on certain points and there's always
some kind of purgative
element to the IOWASCA.
But that night I was like
shitting and vomiting.
Like I had,
like there was some evil in my body
that was trying to escape like the most
violent purge I've ever had in my life.
It was,
and it went on for hours. I don't know
where stuff was coming out of my body.
Right. And I've, I've done,
I watched it many times,
so I know what the normal purchase this
was. They have outhouses or five times.
Now the, you have a little toilet in
your, in your place. Sometimes toilet.
Uh, depends. Sometimes no.
Sometimes that's just a hole.
And sometimes you do have running
water depending on where you go,
but a lot of times they don't have toilet
lids because you're not supposed to
sit there and really enjoy, you're
supposed to just hover, blow it out,
and then wipe and put it in a basket.
That's kind of the general program,
but put it in a basket.
Yeah. Cause it can't,
they can't keep it in the toilet paper
around the system. Yeah. Oh. But anyway,
so there's some kind of cleansing
aspect to it. It doesn't make any sense.
The science, I don't know, I don't
understand, but I know that, you know,
they believe it's a cleansing ritual and
it's certainly had that effect on me.
Wow. It just blows it out.
And then that tobacco,
he kicked it in something, something
and he blew a lot of smoke, all of them.
And then the next day he sees me and
he starts laughing as I'm walking,
like walking by him, he just
starts laughing and getting,
he asked me, you know,
how was last night? And
he's, I had someone with me,
you can help me translate.
And I was like,
what the hell did you do to me?
And he's just laughing and laughing and
just pats me on the back and just keeps
on walking. Like he knew that's
exactly what he was going to do. Wow.
So he was doing that just to get you to
get rid of all the shit inside of you
and throw up,
cleaned it all out and then dose up
the next night while dragging juice.
Exactly.
And the next night was the night that
I went out and did the ride on that
smuggled. That makes sense. Wow.
He cleans your system out with
some smoke stuff that they found
DMT and the pineal gland of live
rats. Huge. Yeah. Huge. Yeah.
This is Rick Strassman's
Cottonwood Research Foundation.
He, um, he, uh, just, uh,
I mean this is something that they
had speculated for the longest time.
I thought it was a fact.
I thought that they had known it was a
fact until a Voodoo chicken on my message
board was I think the first guy to,
to clue me in to the fact that there's
only like anecdotal evidence and he was
like challenging Strassman on
the message board because, uh,
we know that the human body produces it.
Then they, I guess they knew it produced,
it was produced in the
liver and the lungs,
but this is the first time they can prove
that at least in rodents it's in the
pineal gland of alive.
Right? Yeah. I think when you,
and when you're the way that,
let's suppose it was the spirit mark,
right?
Let's suppose that hypothesis is true
and it is some part of conducting the
spirit from source into life
and then back out. You know,
let's say that there is some
activation for that. Um,
it makes sense that they wouldn't find
the active concentrations in the dead
Peniel glands because presumably
it's purpose was done there.
But to see it there in
live, in live, um, you know,
and while it's living
I think is pretty cool,
at least opens up that
theory as a possible.
One of the interesting things
about taking the DMT was
the,
the shortness of the trip and that's
what the thing that people was coming on,
that one of the signs that this isn't,
this isn't a deadly drug, is how easy
your body can get rid of it. Yeah. Your,
your body can get rid of it and bring
you back to baseline in 15 minutes.
Like you're on this voyage to another
dimension and then 15 minutes later your
body's like, okay, okay.
Nothing to see here. We just get to clean
this up folks. Yeah. What'd you cook?
And just come in there with a broom
and sweep up all the memories.
What you just did.
Um, it, it seems like your body
knows what to do with this shit.
It obviously makes it, we know
it makes it, we know that,
but now we know that literally the third
eye makes it and that's fucking crazy
because that's,
that's literally,
I hate when I say literally because I
shouldn't have said it that many times.
That was my version of Ugh, that
was literally, I should have said,
ah.
Anyway,
they've proven that at least in rodents,
this sacred of all sacred glands,
this gland that the Egyptians
thought was the seat of the soul,
this gland,
that eastern mysticism had forever
connected with an eye of enlightenment,
that that gland produces the most
potent psychedelic drug known to man.
That's fucking bananas.
Pretty wild. It's nuts.
So many cross cultures too that you know,
have,
have some kind of belief in
that center of your, you know,
in that center of your forehead where
your pineal gland is. It's pretty,
it's pretty unique. And you know, the
shamans down there, the interesting thing,
you know,
and I was reading Danieli Billy's book
about creating your own religion and the
distinctions between
religion and you know,
what both feel as like true spirituality.
And some of it is, you know,
it's not people telling you
that it's, you know, feeling it,
it's feeling that kind of activation
or feeling what that feels like.
And there's been times when I've been
taking Iowasca where my most intense
experiences come with a really intense
buzzing energy that feels like not only
that part of my head but starting there,
the energy feels like it peels off my
whole scalp starting in my third eye,
middle of my forehead region,
all the way to the back of my head,
what they would call the Crown Chakra.
And I don't know too much about chocolates
but I know that that's what I felt
from right here to the back of my head.
It was like somebody peeled it off and
it had an electric field and electric
current over it.
And when you get that feeling,
you know you're in for some fucking
cool shit that Redmond cool shit happen.
Like that is the precursor to the
craziest experiences of your, of your
spiritual oh yeah. Yeah. It's,
it's,
it's a language that you can only speak
with people who've had some form of
experience,
something.
Cause there's a lot of people out there
and there's nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with going through.
I don't think there's anything wrong with
going through your whole life as long
as you're enjoying it.
Why?
Why have a psychedelic
experience if you don't want to,
if you don't feel compelled, I feel like
if you feel compelled, give it a shot.
But when you're having these conversations
and you're talking about your shock,
we're blowing open and putting
yourself to dimensions and Phis,
crazy flotillas or serpents flying
above your head. I hear you.
And I'm like, yeah, wow,
okay, wow. Fucking hey.
Like I know that really happened because
I've seen some crazy shit myself.
Not that it really happened. Not
that it's really a snake, but,
but my point that what people always
go, well you know, if it's not real,
okay then you're doing something
really infant tile. Okay.
You're taking something that's allowing
you to go into fantasy land for a little
while maybe.
Or listen,
what if I could prove that it takes you
to another dimension and the in that
other dimension,
you will see things that you could not
possibly have imagined and you will
experience novelty and honesty and wisdom
in love in the purest forms possible,
like their joy,
like their waves hitting you where
you're standing on the beach.
If I could tell you that it was definitely
taking you to another dimension,
would you go then? I don't know.
Maybe not, but here's what I know.
Here's what I know for sure.
If it took you to another dimension,
you had that experience or if you
just had that experience in your head,
you still have that experience and I
might as well have taken you to another
dimension. It might as well
because the same thing happened.
You saw the same shit.
You felt the same things.
You experienced the same things you saw
at all. It might not have been real,
but it might've been real too.
It doesn't matter.
You still experienced exactly the same
way as if it did take you to another
planet and you did ride around the rings
of Saturday and your underwear. I mean,
it really does take you to that place.
Yeah.
So it might be real,
it might take you to that place or it
might be all happening in your mind,
but either way you experienced
the exact same thing
and it lasts. And the results there, you
know, that you get from it are actually,
that was one of the cool things
about going to the maps conference,
which is the Multidisciplinary
Association of Psychedelic Studies.
They put on a conference in Oakland and
they had all of the top scientists from
all these different fields of research
come and present their findings.
So there's been over 80 patients,
clinically dose with Psilocybin.
Most of them in palliative care easing
the anxiety of death towards the end of
life.
Amazing dramatic stories.
You have psychiatrists in there who'd
been working in this field for 40 years,
seeing people and they, they're the ones
running these, uh, these programs. And,
well, first of all, the funny part is
it's, it's a double blind trial, right?
So it was on one case someone is getting
placebo which is doing nothing and
another case they're getting
a heroic dose of Psilocybin.
And the research is like,
one of the problems with the study design
is we pretty much know because they're
not supposed to know it's double blind.
We pretty much know when someone's taken
a bunch of siliciden like it's not hard
to tell when that's actually happened,
but they're saying that what they're
accomplishing in three hours would take on
them three years to do back in the
old paradigm and their reporting these
findings and it's really encouraging.
Obviously the Johns Hopkins
study was a great study.
94% of people who took the psilocybin
said it was one of the top five most
meaningful experience of their life.
I mean really cool findings that are
leading to a potential legalization of
psilocybin for clinical use and
shouldn't be just for clinical use.
This is what's really fucked up.
It's all these people that are having
all these thoughts and all these positive
experiences like that,
that this is discounted by our government.
Gish. It shows that were being run by
a bunch of infants like they should be
experiencing it too.
You should also do mushrooms as well.
Sir, are prerequisite, prerequisite
for political. This for sure.
It's such a silly little thing. It gloat
grows and cow shit. It looks ridiculous.
It sounds ridiculous. It
appears in fucking Mario
Brothers, Donkey Kong and shit,
but it might be the thing that humanity
really could count on right now.
It might be the thing if you could ensure
across the board experiences ensured
them worldwide over a
week's period of time.
You changed the world forever and that's
real. Yeah. You really would. One,
one gigantic world trip where like 30%
of the population of the planet does
mushrooms. One day you want
to talk about a strange world.
You would wake up to Monday morning.
Fuck yeah.
I mean people would be
hugging people in the streets.
This is a thought I've had recently.
What if all of the churches instead of
just bickering about their own dogmas and
all this stuff, I mean they're all
trying to get at the same spirit.
What if they were all churches have
experience and across the war there was,
you know,
one basic church that you go to and that
church was a little bit of everything.
In that church,
there was zen meditation in one area,
there was float tanks in another area,
there was lectures from people like
Graham Hancock coming through there.
There was yoga in one spot.
And then there is different ceremonial
areas where you could smoke pot and do,
you know, do it dance out in uh, out in a
sweat lodge. Or You could take mushrooms,
take mushrooms in a clinical, you
know, like a really relaxed, you know,
encouraging setting.
Or You could do an Iowasca ceremony with
the local Iowasca Maestro and all of
that was available to you.
So you look,
maybe you didn't go every week or every
Sunday, but when you needed to check in,
there was your local church and you
could just kind of talk to some people,
either listen,
maybe do some light yoga,
or let's say you really needed to move
yourself and then go in and pop into an
IOWASCA ceremony. Or let's say
you were feeling, you know,
you got addicted to
something accidentally. Oh,
well you could pop into the Boga treatment
ceremony that last through him Sunday
through Tuesday.
Real clinics like that.
There were run by people really
knew what they were doing.
I could change the whole world,
the whole thing.
The whole paradigm shifts at that
point, I think. And it's there.
It's like a real thing.
That's what's crazy.
It's not like something from
a doctor Seuss book, you know,
that rhymes with you no more.
You know what I mean? Like, yeah,
they took them off on top of the
org and traveled to a farm. I do.
I am really encouraged by what,
um,
what maps is doing because they're,
they're playing by the rules and you
think that you get nowhere playing by the
rules, but in some
encouraging results, both,
both for Mbma for PTSD and
he's psilocybin studies,
they're getting allowed to do the research
to complete these phase one trials
and actually test them on human subjects
for the first time in a long time.
And that's going to lead to bigger trials
in the phase two trials and the phase
three and eventually there's going
to get drug approvals for these.
Now why that is significant
is that that point,
you have a massive amount of data.
You have side effects studied,
you have clinical use study,
and if you can prove that there is an
actual benefit to something, you know,
it really weakens the
argument for criminalization.
And then of course there's going
to be a lot of off label uses.
Doctors who are like, look, this
is really helpful. You know,
just kind of like what's happened
with medical marijuana a little bit.
It's been medically legal,
but pretty much that is the
gateway to legalization.
But they're following the steps along the
path that could potentially allow this
to be legal.
There's that path and then there's the
religious freedom path and I think those
are really the only two paths that are
going to lead to fruitful and effective
policy change. Religious freedom
is a funny thing. It's just,
I always feel like whenever someone
gets together in a big giant group and
there's a few people running,
it shit goes bad. It's just,
it seems very rare than anybody
can keep it together. You know?
It all just turns a little.
I've been reading,
I've been listening rather to a Dan
Carlin's hardcore history about Martin
Luther and the the rise of the
Anabaptists in Munster, Germany,
whenever some new dude comes along and
tries to change things and we're going to
do it the right way, it's just how
God wanted it. It always goes bad.
It always goes bad,
but somebody gets in trouble and then
they start just because they realize they
can fuck all the teenage girls
and suddenly God tells him that that's
what they need to do. When this guy died,
he had 16 wives.
Exactly.
It's always the same and they just
chopped him apart with swords and shit and
eventually got a hold of them.
You know what,
the other thing I've been kind of
thinking about is too is you know,
you assume that like some of these Iowasca
Schamens at bogus schamens different
people. You would assume that by doing
those psychedelic drugs they would've
straightened themselves out.
They would have straightened
their morality out and
they'd be all good people.
But that's certainly not
the case. You know, they,
there are a lot of examples of these
people who are doing the medicine itself
and are still completely
morally corrupt individuals.
And I was just so weird. Yeah,
it is weird. But you know,
I think ultimately the power of the mind,
you know,
if you put your mind to it can supersede,
at the potential of the medicine itself.
So if you decide to it and just use
the feeling, it's almost like taking,
you know, mushrooms
recreationally to watch a cartoon,
you can kind of override the potential
spiritual value of it and just focus on
laughter and seeing colors explode on a
screen in the same way that you can do
it with morality where you can take
a bunch of Iowasca and then use that,
override it still with your mind and
just use it to practice whatever kind of
power mechanism you want. So you
gotta make sure you get, you know,
just because they do a bunch of,
uh, well Huska or vogue or whatever,
it doesn't mean they're good. You got
to find the people who are on that,
that True Path,
the path of light.
So you think what happens is
probably these people grow
up in this horrible area,
you know,
third world country,
really impoverished and they probably
find out about Iowasca as a way to make
money because there's an eye on WASC at
tourists trade aid. Even if they take it,
maybe when you just reach a certain amount
of fucked up, there's no, no Poland.
You back to to civilization.
You know,
maybe the way the human body is programmed
to survive and horrible destitute
situations. Yeah, really, really
disgusting violent situations.
The human body sort of designed to to,
to be able to function
in those environments and
knows how to change and get
wacky and crazy and it knows
how to deal with war. It adapts,
adapts and that becomes the new reality
that becomes every day to day living now.
And it just seems like when you go just
a certain distance down the cut whole,
you know,
it's like there's no pulling you back.
That's true. Or perhaps in, in other
cases I think it's happened, you know,
a lot of these traditions are taught
grandfather to grandson and I think the
grandchildren start off, you
know, on a pretty good path.
But then they get a taste of power.
Then they realize everybody in their area,
if it's a tribe or if in their community
looks up to them and they have absolute
power over these people,
and you put that amount,
that mantle of power on people and
you'll see cracks develop. You know,
you see it all over the place.
People who were once good,
getting in power and
exposing these inner demons,
these inner weaknesses that they have
and they choose instead of overcoming
those that choose to just go with it.
I bet a lot of their downfall is chicks
from America with yoga pants come down
there. And I'm just trying
to get spiritually clean.
I'm just trying to open up my shockers
and just big juicy ass and yoga pants
just,
and she's in love with this dude because
he makes the magic brew and he knows
how to call the dragon dump, dump, dump,
dump, dump, dump, dump, dump, dump.
And she's in fucking seethrough yoga
pants. Do you know they just fix those.
See through yoga pants? What took so
long? Think they should give them all out.
That's the only fair thing to do.
They should have shut the fuck
up is what they should have done.
You knew what you were doing.
You dirty freaks. Who? What?
Girl doesn't put those on and
get in front of a mirror. Yeah.
Oh my God.
You can see everything.
I can't wear these. Oh my
God. You can see everything.
Should I wear these, if you would
you think wasn't I wore these.
Oh my God. You can see it.
Can you see everything? Can
you, am I being picky? They,
they talk themselves out of it.
They know that their boxes just hanging
out there and a lot of these dirty
freaks would go to yoga class with
nothing on just these yoga tights and
literally you could read their
lips. You literally, there's,
I said literally five times after I said,
I hate that I said it literally.
You did fuck cunt cunt. Fuck yeah.
The only thing that this company
should do is just hand them out.
They should just shut the fuck up.
They should just go radio silent selling,
keep selling them and go
radio silent and they go,
are these the these yoga pants
still see through? Just go, Huh,
Huh, Huh, Huh. Yeah. It looks great
in, yeah, those are good for you.
Go the dressing rooms over there if
you want to get changed or if they get
sweaty,
you can see through them.
Just have a nice bright dressing room
so none of those freaks can try foul.
Just let them steal it. I'm looking
at, look at your box in the mirror.
That's wrong with that. That's a
little showing off a little block.
How's that going to hurt anybody?
It'd be good for everybody. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Except schamens thing.
They use those American Yoga freaks. They
used to a bunch of barefoot fishermen.
Women. Yeah, it's true. I mean
too much. Too much to bear.
It's milky white scan and a big juicy
booty and stretching out in the jungle
floor. You just get yoga
pants. I find on roses,
all the ones from Lulu lemon or
maybe invest in hyper color. I mean,
I bet that's pretty cheap and it just is.
And we put out Alpha tights
for guys to show their cocks.
They'll still be the new, uh,
the new alpha thing. Alpha
tights. Everybody was like,
why do I have to wear,
why do I have to wear underwear?
I'm just gonna wear tights and dudes
who just wear tights everywhere,
but they're see through tights.
We could just really show your cock and
that becomes a new thing. Well look it,
I would believe that would be the new
thing before it would ever believe that
there'd be dudes willing to pull their
pants down to their balls and then belt
them in place there.
And you have your underwear hanging out.
And if this would be like a super common
practice and then I'd be walking on the
street and I'd see five 10 20 young men
with their fucking pants pulled down
below the crack of their ass.
And I'm like, what are you doing?
Do you know stupid?
This is so,
I wouldn't believe that that
will be possible. And it
is. So I believe that the,
the,
the cock tights,
we'd be the shit was it from you that
we were talking about that that was part
of prison culture.
And they don't have belts.
You can't have belts cause
you can choke someone.
Definitely you could kill yourself.
And so they would sag their pants.
Easy access for their,
for their daddies to just bend them over.
Well, the, the, the booty
master was that guy's name,
the one got the booty bandit who
was in that aisle locked up show.
You ever seen that show? No. You've never
seen that Brian. Please pull that up.
Since we have this amazing Internet
connection now the booty booty bandit from
locked up or they also call and the most
terrifying man on earth or something
like that. But he was all talking
about dudes that are sagging, you know,
and then he
goes, to me, that's sexy. He's like that
sexy like you, you sang in front of me.
Yeah. You find that this is a huh?
This guys to fucking terrified it.
Kentucky state penitentiary.
We met police jobs. The booty
warrior a long time. That's
what it costs him. Sorry.
Different kinds of
homosexuality, right? Yeah,
he does sexual dissolves,
right.
Sean [inaudible] and a
warm place all along,
get home or [inaudible] all they home
made a map warming [inaudible] and it say
the most memorable story
that's police told us to look.
That guy looks like the type of guy
that he would lock get his cell.
Why don't they just fucked to death?
Why don't they just sit in like returns
like flashlights are returns, you know,
it was a good one.
Just send out a person.
I did talk to the system and Moody.
They weren't, they weren't down with it.
Um, more important. Boody was more
important than for a man, but,
oh no, no. He had the first half. Correct.
And the second half wrong.
It looked low. Booming.
I ave to bullying.
What's more important? Drank them. Wow.
Oh my goodness. That's it. It's enough.
I've heard enough to boody warrior.
I was listening to a,
I was listening to my buddy Donald shorts.
He was out actually in Hayward.
They're chasing down rhino poachers,
which was a pretty crazy experience
because they're going after these rhino
poachers that are killing these Ryan.
I was just cutting off the horn,
selling them to China to make Chinese
People's Dick's bigger supposedly,
which is really all it is. It's all, it's
all, that's what they use it for. Yeah.
That's the main thing they use it for
is they grind it up and put it in Dick
Pills in China.
And it's really the same thing that's in
your fingernails like it has. No, yeah,
it has no actual properties that are
doing anything. But there's the big horn,
big Dick. And I don't know if
it's, I apologize about my accent,
but he didn't apologize. You would have
been fine problems. You didn't own it,
but the uh,
but whatever in that paradigm there as
one of the reasons for these riders going
to kill it. So he goes out
there, it's crazy. They end up,
they end up shooting this footage and
then as they're coming up on these
poachers, they get shot at.
Why, why? This is all on video.
If you look up Donald Sholtz Rhino,
I don't know what you can find it,
but they get shot at by these poachers
and then you see him duck down like oh
shit. And they're filming this and then
his people, his, his people pop up,
he's from South Africa,
his people pop up with like eight ks
and just lay waste to where the poachers
and the poachers have high powered rifles.
These guys have like assault rifles.
Right. But they shot first Adam and
it's a shoot to kill policy apparently.
But then they roll up on the poachers,
one of them is dead,
one of them was wounded.
It's this crazy kind of scenario.
But the poachers are in leagues
with the actual police in there.
It's all there paying them off.
It's all part of the money system.
So as they were leaving,
they get stopped by the police and
they're looking for footage of, you know,
kind of what went down and they hid the
footage and I think some parachute bags
or something like that. And
police are giving him hell
and they just go, you know,
we're going to throw you in jail and
you're going to come out different.
And what they meant by that was it,
there's something called slow puncture
where they put you in a cell with another
do with HIV,
and then he rapes you.
And then they let you go after
he rapes you enough times.
And then you go home and
you die of aids at home.
And they call it slow puncture for people
that they can't actually press charges
on. Whoa. But they want
to fuck you for life.
And so there they were
threatening him with that,
but they held the bluff
berm got the tapes out.
And I've been trying to raise
awareness to, uh, to save the rhinos.
But it's scary. It's scary.
Slow puncture in an African prison sign.
Don't do it.
Don't do it. How fucking terrifying. And
if you do, if you're about to get raped,
just fight for your goddamn
life. That's it. There's no,
no point. We're going to war. Yeah, you're
going to war to the death. First Day.
You probably gonna die. You may
die, most likely it's likely,
but go out on your shield, son,
go out on your shield, son.
Don't go to Africa. That's another one.
Imagine if Africa was the only place left.
Imagine if there was some
crazy fucking catastrophe.
Most of the world got wiped out except
the content Africa and we all hopped over
there and boats from all over the world
and battled it out for a chunk of the
Congo. Carve your stake in
Africa. The rest of the world,
just to waste just a giant wasteland,
a small,
well Africa's Hmong population,
you know all the people and influences
and all the bullshit, all the corruption.
That's fucked it up.
There's a lot that's fuck through that
place and it's so fucked up in so many
ways. It's like, how do you bring
some Malia back? You know? Very true.
How do you bring Liberia back?
How do you,
how do you snap those back to
the standards of, you know,
European cities like London?
I Dunno.
I mean the corruption is so deep seated.
There's that problem and then there's the,
you know,
kind of Middle East fundamentalists.
Sure. It's, it's also like you,
nobody has any desire to go and use
resources to help these poor people out.
And these people who live in Liberia or
live in Somalia or live in any of their
really poor sections of Africa,
like they got a really shit roll
the dice location wise. They, they,
they were born and incredibly impoverished
place and it's like there's gotta be
something that the rest of the world like
gotta like be honest about where these
people are. The rest of where
I was like, well, you know,
they can pull themselves up by their
bootstraps just like we did over here in
Munich,
but now like the infrastructure of spots,
it's like so much better to get
born in those spots. I mean,
they're in the slums, you know,
you would see these shanty's,
he's little shacks of basically sheet
metal and that's it. Sheet metal.
And they kind of put it towards the
ground just to keep a little sun off of
their head and a little bit of shade in
the day. But they'd be on hills, right.
And there's no septic system,
so they'd be on,
so the people at the top of the hill
just be going in the bathroom in their
huts and the sewage would just slide
oh the rest of the places
down and meet that. And you know,
disease was everywhere. You see.
And it's a really intense,
intense scenario and
generally a very good people.
But one of the thing and very
cool people there that you meet,
but one of the problems is,
is that there's so the best way
to get ahead in Africa right now,
the way to get the most money is not
start a business, be an entrepreneur,
create something. It's to get a grant. So
we have some of the, like the brightest,
smartest Africans instead of
like trying to create businesses.
And of course some of them do.
But I noticed a lot of really the
smartest people I meet, we're coming,
trying to write grants and just trying
to get money instead of focusing on
starting a business,
building something from the grass roots.
So it's almost like some of the help that
we're providing is not really helping
longterm. It's just their
gaming it, you know,
they're figuring out the game
and trying to get the money out.
Well that is a fascinating aspect of
that Bot Africa is that, that's the,
the head, the Nigerians cameras. I mean
they're so famous. Nigerian scammers,
like everybody has heard
about Nigerian scams.
There's been so many of them and so
many of them were the dudes just get so
duped. Like it's always like a guy
and they pretend that they're a girl.
Then the gold out loud. Yeah. I
can't get the gold deer. So easy.
It is to get gold anywhere.
Everybody will buy gold.
So if anybody comes to you and says,
Hey, I just can't sell it as gold man,
they're full of shit. And the other one
is they like to do the inheritance one.
You even Harris, you have to
pay some legal fees, right?
Just a few grand in legal fees
and the money's coming, bro.
Fucking go to the craziest
thing you've ever seen.
You never run out of money forever. Start
buying a house. I mean, you can use it.
You don't even need a down payment.
Just tell them about this and then
you'll just take money in the bank.
Nigerian scammers,
I guess they just got like Super Desperado
a bunch of smart dudes and then just
hopped in and started figuring out how
scam white people or they're not even
Nigerians and somebody else
just hopped on the fucking, oh,
Nigerian scams are working,
let's do it. Right.
Like they didn't know shit about Nigeria.
They took it to the next level.
They pretended to be Nigeria.
Right.
But they're really like from
Sweden or some shit. Like go ahead.
I was just going to say, speaking
of uh, Sweden or some shit,
I was thinking of foreign countries where
this guy can go that leaked this, uh,
the NSA documents who's a, he's
hiding, you know, this whole story.
They had more than other wiki
leaks. Kinda. Yeah, exactly.
The one that showed us that the NSA
has been following, uh,
every phone call on Verizon.
So in collecting metadata about every,
every transaction you've had, every,
every interaction that you've had,
what do you think the ultimate end
game is for that? I guess it's,
if anybody you know is a problem,
they can just go back to the records and
fuck you up. Right. Is that the idea?
Cause they're not going to be able to
pour through that data and just pick on
people because someone said, Oh yeah,
I'm going to smoke some weed or whatever.
I mean I really don't think
that's the plan. I think
it's just they have it. Yeah.
Just in case they need to, I think,
yeah, that's the, I knock you down.
It's not that they want
to invade your privacy,
but that if you turn out to be a creep,
they want it to be really easy to
be able to pull out any data on you.
The problem is that it's like,
so are welling in and you're giving
people this incredible power to peer into
People's privacy and you know, what do we
lose in return for that? Well we really,
really, we lose all privacy because all
privacy when you're interacting with,
unless you're talking in a, in
a closed room. And even then,
like if you go into like foreign places,
like literally like working on secret
shit, like you know embassies and stuff,
they won't let you bring iPhones.
Do you know why?
Because you can't take a battery out of
an iPhone. And Amber Lyon taught us that.
Like she's gone in like when
she was working for CNN,
she'd do these like big time interviews
and she would have to get an android
phone so they could take the battery
out cause they want, don't want anybody,
otherwise I can have that thing working
remotely and they can spy on you.
I mean all that technology is available.
They could just set your phone off while
you're hanging it out in your office,
planning your dastardly attack
on Gotham city, you know,
with your fucking superhero friends or
whatever and they can record it all.
You know,
that would,
that would be less scary if every law
in the u s was perfectly just right.
You know,
there was only just laws.
You're allowed to experiment with your
own consciousness, you know, whatever.
All of these other financial
system has to get cleaned up first.
But imagine that, I mean, all the shit
that we're worried about, what are,
what are we worried about?
We're worried about I smoking weed.
I guess someone could fuck you up.
Maybe if you would have,
if you're being unfaithful
to your girlfriend,
but it shouldn't be doing that
shit anyways. But you know,
that's something that it's still,
it's nobody's business.
But if at least the laws were just, then
it wouldn't be such a pain in the ass.
But because we have all these unjust laws
where we can be thrown in jail for an
indefinite period of time, you know? Well,
those two kind of scary for everybody.
Those two things you brought up to,
she'd have absolutely nothing to do with
the law in fidelity or marijuana or is
it nothing to do with the law should
be all about protecting people,
protecting people from violence,
protecting people from theft,
protecting people from injustice and,
and ensuring a harmonious
community and that,
you know,
that's really what it should,
all the laws where you'd be pumped to see
the cops, how sweet the cops are here.
Awesome. They're going to keep
everything safe. You know,
instead of me like I'm on
the or stop creeping. Well,
you know, I've been really,
like I said it,
listen to this Dan Carlin podcasts.
I've listened to dozens of them over
the last couple of weeks and it's,
it's amazing how good we have it today
just compared to like the 15 hundreds
like the way the people were living
just 500 plus years ago. It's just,
it's total insanity.
Total insanity. We would,
we have been hell if we're
forced to be back there.
It was such a short period of time ago.
It's like we without a doubt there's
a lot of room for improvement in this
society and its culture,
but we're seeing an awareness right in
front of our eyes that I'm not even sure
if we've totally understood the impact
of it yet because what you're seeing with
like this NSA leak thing and wiki leaks,
you're seeing this forced
response in this grand global way.
Like they have to respond to these things
in a global way like the whole UK is,
they were writing articles about it in
newspapers are writing articles about it.
Hong Kong. The fact that this guy was
on the run, the FBI's looking for them.
This is a worldwide publicity disaster
for the NSA and it's been created by one
person who took a stand and now they're
going after that person as if he's some
sort of a terrorist. One
person that showed that, hey,
you guys are kind of violating the
constitution. Like what's going on here?
Do we have a constitution anymore?
Oh No,
this NDA thing that you've fucks past
that sort of bypass the constitution.
So now all this illegal shit or that
used to be illegal, you made it legal.
So you think you're doing an okay job.
Is that what's going on here?
This is clearly bad.
Governing is clearly,
and I think that transparency is being
exhibited in like this reaction to this
NSA whistleblower thing where people,
you know,
like the president's can
having to defend it now.
And one of the things he was saying,
I was just talking about this to Dunkin,
we were talking about how Obama was like,
you know,
well this is something we should
definitely have a debate about. We can,
I'm definitely open to talking
about this will really,
well why was it a secret then? Yeah.
Why did somebody have to leak this?
Why didn't you discuss this with people
and explain the pros and cons of losing
this much secrecy of losing this
much privacy. That's ridiculous.
That's [inaudible]. There's, there's
not that many threats to this world.
I don't buy it. I think they're doing
a great job and shutting down threats.
If you stop and look at how many threats
and they've turned into actual terror
attacks besides the Boston one and
besides a couple of other ones,
there's very few,
very few there.
When you compare them to
actual days of the week,
you compare them to actual human
interactions that take place throughout 50
states and numerous cities all
throughout the day, all over the time.
There's very few like those
shitheads from Boston.
There's very few like you know,
whether it's a a nine 11 that happened
in 2001 or cause they can squash most of
them without reading every fucking email
you saying they shouldn't be able to
read everybody shit. That's
ridiculous. You know,
I think if you could
prove that you were just,
and that you were looking out
for the best interest of man,
maybe you should be able to go and like
look into this stuff without a warrant.
But because it's been proven like the
IRS goes after conservative tea party
groups like mark much more than they
go after liberal people. They like,
they just got busted for doing that.
Like chasing down these tea party Fox and
making their life hell harassing them,
like making their, their, their experience
with paying their, they're just taxes.
Much more diff
gold. Well the beauty is is
that the age of information,
the Internet is allowing all of these
people to band together and make a force
on their own.
But it's back in the day.
Imagine if you had to gather a large
group of people, you know, have,
you couldn't do it.
You have to put out an ad and then
you'd have to get that ad approved by
whatever newspaper you were going to do.
I mean,
or find a reputable news outlet that
you could go tell your story too.
But now with the Internet,
these things can spread and these things
can gather and people can communicate
and that's a force that I don't think the
powers that be are fully comprehending
and are ready to reckon with
Dianne Feinstein was explaining that we
needed to do these things because uh,
we need to stop terrorism. And
she was, when she was saying this,
I was imagining that this
person gets to speak for me.
I was imagining like the
ridiculousness of this,
this person getting to speak for me,
this silly person who,
if there was a couple of us and she
started talking to me, be like, okay,
stop talking. You're talking nonsense.
Like you're talking nonsense.
If she was just around us right now and
she was explaining why that would be
important, she would look like a
buffoon within a couple of minutes time.
She would be stammering.
It would be a disaster. It.
There's no argument there and there's not
a single argument that you could point
to where a competent society that cares
about its citizens and he cares about
the quality of life,
which includes respect for your privacy,
that that culture would allow these ass
fucks to just download every email you
send. Dunkin had a great way of
describing it today. He said,
could you imagine if the
government in the 1960 said, hey,
everybody that sends a
letter through the mail,
we're going to take it and xerox it
and then we're not going to read it,
but we're going to have it and then we're
going to send it back to you and we're
going to just keep all your letters in
a storage facility in Utah. If you like,
get the fuck Outta here. You know how to
get to read my letters. Why do you need,
you're just because when a person calls
themselves a cops or the CIA or the FBI,
they put themselves into
some sort of a group.
Now suddenly they believe they have
power that a regular person doesn't have
because it was only two
people on the planet.
You and Mister FBI guy
and Mr Fbi guys like,
I believe you might be plotting terrorism.
So I'm going to read your emails,
your emails to who you fuck is this you
and me? No, you can't read my email.
Get outta here. Go Fuck
Yourself. You're just a person.
But when you're in a group and you're
the NSA or the CIA or the FBI or any
fucking other three letters,
you want to string together,
all of a sudden you have the to go
and do really rude shit to people,
you know, and that, that's the
problem with the big groups and
rude by throwing them in jail. And it
definitely, I mean beyond, right? I mean,
it's rude. It's hurting. Your
girlfriend reads your phone, text,
even if you haven't done
anything wrong. You know, it's,
it's rude when people dig into
people's fast. It's a, I mean I write,
I write in journals and things like that
and one of like the most sacred things
to me is that nobody picks
those motherfuckers up
because if somebody goes in
and reads that journal,
that means that every time I'm
riding my innermost thoughts,
there's going to be a little
sensor voice up there saying,
oh well what if somebody reads this shit?
I better not write this exactly how it is.
As soon as that sensor voice comes on,
the whole,
the whole practice of writing
in the journalist, fuck.
That's why you shut up and write
in a journal after you beat off.
That way you're at your most honest
really didn't know you're a piece of shit.
Spell it out.
Got Out of a situation
where somebody did that.
You know where somebody went in my phone
and screen shot it every single text I
have every single photo, every singe
thing and send it to themselves and that,
that now questions me
when I talked to anybody.
Cause even if it's something legit,
I don't even want to type it
down anymore because of that.
I mean there's like that program
that's popular right now.
Snapchat where you send a photo and
then it expires in three seconds of your
balls and stuff.
People found out a way to hack that and
now so you can go in there and take all
those photos and all those videos
that are supposed to be gone forever.
Very well. All you have
to do, there's so silly.
All you have to do is have two
phones, right? And you took a photo,
a photo of the photo and that way you
don't even have to get a screenshot of the
game.
There was so many to week game that we
gave this sweet Dinah shots that you just
sense it.
All these motherfuckers are playing
tic TAC toe and there's no girls with
workable vaginas that we're going
to send good pictures anyway.
It's all the game's terrible.
It's a terrible game.
But that is something
that is scary though.
If you think about texting
is so popular nowadays,
you don't realize what you're
typing the people, right?
Like you're typing secrets that only you
and that person supposed to know. Right.
You know,
and then like six months later the NSA,
you lose your phone or you lose your
phone, you're like, oh look at this guy.
What he's talking about. Oh look at this.
Oh you don't think a shit like that?
You should make your journal.
You should,
you should like write it in like a very
specific like do you have those, um,
you know those a scholastic
white and black book covers,
it's like that was weird pattern that
they had and it was a hard cover TV.
Well you should only write in those,
right?
And write my journal and then make up
a dummy one with one of those ink bombs
like they have for bags that they give
away and during the bank robberies and
once you open somebody
ship whammy, right? Yeah,
yeah.
Green with envy and rotten desire,
but you fucking green fuck head all.
I like dirty
green,
like a rotten stinking green or not.
Don't write ridiculous shit paper
and leave it around your house.
If I was staying over your house,
I'm probably fucking read it.
If I want to use your bathroom
and I took a leak and it was like,
what is this motherfucker writing on
the shitter reading? And you're like,
why are you still in there
man? Oh Dude, I'm constipated.
And then you realize that your book is
in there and I'm reading your book most
likely. Yeah, don't leave your back. Don't
leave your journal in the shitter. Yeah,
but I ain't going to cut it.
I only have books in the shitter if I'm
not taking my cal shakes because if I,
if I'm on a regular Kale shake
program, the job done, I always,
the way I describe it is like a tunnel
and then those zombies from world war Z
or running down down the tunnel,
just all stacking on top of each other.
That's what the Kale shake is.
It just fills up your entire
pipe with a thick green,
gooey substance.
Cause I down about 30 ounces and then
those motherfuckers just push everything
out and it's a wild ride.
That's what, yeah man. You
know what dude? I told you we,
I'm someone on the message board actually
found out how much of that shit is in
Kale. Right. As opposed to other
things. Salary has more than Kale.
The doctor said that while he was here.
I don't know,
I feel good but the Dave Asprey,
how dare you. But he said that on the
podcast but it's still has a lot in it.
I don't think he said that.
I think he said salary had last actually
he was whoever the corrected them
online. Apparently they corrected
them. What he said was incorrect.
It's just a mistake whatever he said.
But the way to combat that apparently
that's effective is calcium and adding
calcium to your Kale shake. It's supposed
to offset the effects of any of that.
Take your nightly TPC.
It's got it in there.
But what I was going to say is people
discount how you know the feedback that
you're getting from your body yourself.
You know like you feel good when
you have a Kale shake, right?
Like you can feel it. Like if there
was something poisonous in that,
I really trust that the body would
be like, Yo, you know, don't drink,
don't drink this. He feels good
eggs, regular pussy. No it doesn't.
It's supposed to be really warm. But
you know, I mean people, it's the same.
I mean you can apply that same if you're
really kind of pay attention to those
signals coming back, you can
learn a lot from that. And
that's, you know, with this,
you know,
the earth grown nutrients thing that
Mike dolce is always preaching about.
You can tell the difference and then you
get these weird kind of ideas. I mean,
I like a lot of the aspree
principles about high fat,
but if you take some of that stuff too
literally and start hammering like lots
of butter and you just don't feel
that great all the time, you know?
But if you're following a more kind of
common sense and just listening to the
feedback from your body,
it,
I tend to trust that more just kind
of feeling what feels good. Yeah.
But it's also good to have some real
science and knowledge behind it to which
act for sure. Asprey, he takes a lot
of heat but he knows a lot of shit.
It's not a professional,
so if he gets something wrong occasionally
you got to realize that guy also runs
like an it company and people are always
like accusing him of trying to hawk his
items, which he definitely is like
over bulletproofing everything.
I asked him if he had a bulletproof wife
goes home to his bulletproof marriage
and as bulletproof sex, he's just, you
know, he's just, he's starting a business.
He's got getting ideas,
great ideas,
but the point is like that guy had free
shit up on his website for a long time.
There's still a ton of free information.
The Greeley in detail,
excellent stuff that he's pulled down.
He has references,
he tells you where he read it,
he tells you what it's about.
He tells you what the benefits
of these certain things are.
It's really good stuff. And
I know that his, like his,
his thing, his truck, he's like,
he's on a quest to try to figure out
the ultimate combination of foods and
exercises and treatments for
it to rehabilitate injuries.
And he's right about a lot of shit.
Like he me gave me a great tip on that.
Prolozone therapy for back issues. This
fucking tremendous. It's tremendous.
It's got a lot of real wacky idea.
It's bulletproof coffees. Genius Shit.
That's a genius invention.
It's another one of those things
where you can really feel it.
Yeah.
Well the,
the combining it with fats so that it's
a slow release of caffeine. That's,
that's what coffee always needed. That's
what coffee was missing all this time.
Yeah. That fucking jolt that you get
when you down like a 20 ounce Starbucks.
It's black.
You get that weird shaky like,
oh fuck this little druggy
feeling so much, man.
Yeah, but put some butter in there,
put some coconut oil, some MCT.
It changes the game.
Yeah. But just slow that slow
release. That's wonderful.
You know what else has really
changed the game for me?
And maybe I'll tell my whole hunting
story to hear if we want to get into it.
But yeah, I've, uh, you know,
I went out on that hunt down
in south Texas and you know,
we got a lot of meat back from that hunt
and every single time I have that meat
as compared to some other meat,
I mean,
the way that I feel it digest
the way that I feel it absorbing,
it's completely different.
Yeah.
Castiel is completely different than
even if you're buying some kind of grass
fed cow steak, this wild game that we
went out and procured ourselves. I mean,
it's not only delicious.
I mean everything we've had has been
pretty fucking good. Maybe one dud,
but most of the stuff
we're making Fajitas,
we're making stew or making tacos or make
it steaks or making stir fries and all
of this making me hungry.
It's been amazing.
But that was a really cool experience
and it may be something that we've,
I know we've talked about doing
something like that for on it, so,
so really how it could potentially work
and it's a challenging scenario. So,
you know, hopefully we're working,
just know that we're working on it.
Guys potentially make this possible
because I think the health benefits are
there and the whole process is really
valuable because if you've gone your whole
life,
and I know you've made this pitch to,
but if you've gone your whole and all
you do is show up to the grocery store,
pick some cellophane wrapped piece of
meat that all you identify as as a steak.
You know,
you really don't get it.
You really don't understand even what
you're doing. You don't. Yeah. You know,
you don't fully get it until you've
been there inside the animal, you know,
arms up to your arms,
covered in blood,
actually cutting those pieces of
meat out of something you've killed,
that changes your reality,
you know,
then you have a full appreciation
for what you're doing. So,
so what we did out there in south
Texas is there's these ranches,
this one was 10,000 acres.
And so there is a confined space.
It has 10,000 acres,
but these animals are procreating.
They just kind of loosely measuring
the herds because they're mostly wild.
The problem with hunting most native
game is there's very select seasons in
which you're allowed to hunt them.
So you have to really kind of stock up.
If you're going to hunt Whitetail,
you better be in October
and you better have books,
some shit in advance or go
somewhere that's very small seasons.
So what these exotic ranches have done,
if it's non native game,
you're allowed to basically take animals
from the herd all throughout the year.
So they've gotten species of animals
from different parts of the world and
they're just, you know, that
country's version of the
deer. So there's fallow deer,
which come from Europe.
There's some blackbuck which come,
I think they're from Indonesia,
tiger food. There's some access deer,
which also come from around that area.
Blackbuck might be somewhere else, but,
and then there's oryx and addicts and
all these different kinds of antelope and
deer that they get and
they're just living there,
living it up out in south Texas,
the plants down there have roughly 30%
protein and even though they're sparse,
they have pretty good, adequate protein.
And when there is kind of a drought,
they do supplement it with
a little extra food as well.
But they're pretty much just living off
the land and thriving and procreating.
And so you're going down there and not
only is it like a cool safari where
you're seeing all these exotic creatures,
you're actually able to go out and take
your rifle and hop out on some sticks or
you know, track 'em down in
these kind of outdoor vehicles,
which are like these commando
style suburbans and go
hunting for an animal that
you are going to take then and
butcher and have meat for. Man,
I've been eating the same deer
for like three months now.
So it's a really fucking cool experience
where you're out there in land and
these animals are, you know, ostensibly
as wild as, as other animals.
I mean they're not sensitized to
the truck. A few of the species are,
they get kind of used to the truck and
that would be a little weird to shoot.
But these black box,
I mean,
I was out there hunting for the entirety
of the day and I was really didn't
think I was going to get one. You
know, I was hoping to get one,
but I kind of said, you
know, all right, if,
if today's not the right day
to take an animal, so be it.
So rock cruising around in every animal
that came within about 250 yards was
just scattering.
And I knew the ballistics on my,
I wasn't going to comfortably
take a shot that was over about,
you know,
one 50 to one 80,
just because at that point my
particular ballistics on the bullet,
the bullet was going to drop
about four to six inches.
And I didn't really have to
gauge that to gauge that.
But one of those goggles that you look
through and it gives you the number. No,
I didn't have that. So
it was all by, you know,
we had a guide there and he'd be like,
yeah,
that's about one in
one 91 90 get her done.
So, um, so anyway, so we finally,
it's a very end of the day.
I didn't think I was going
to get anything and uh,
we see this blackbuck doe at the very
top of hill about 260 yards away and
instead of scattering I was like,
oh great,
she's just gonna run away like everything
else does instead of scattering away.
It ran like right towards
the truck for 80 yards.
So it was like at 160,
and this is like right when the
sun was kind of starting set.
Definitely the last chance I had.
So I made like a quick makeshift brace,
sod in the cross hairs,
tried to steady my heartbeat pounding
and try to keep the cross hairs from
dancing all over the thing,
seeing sky seeing ground and then focus
in and take a deep breath and then it
just kind of turn just the right way
and I pulled the trigger, you know,
big blast and then it was just
full adrenaline from there.
I saw it rear up in the air,
fell to the ground and I remember running
up to it because I knew that if it was
in pain they say to kind of
wait and see if it gets up.
I wasn't really down with that.
I wanted to make sure that if it was
there that I could, you know, ease.
It's suffering as quickly as possible.
So I just dropped the
gun and went up there.
I knew I hit it pretty
good and sprinted up.
Why'd you jump the gun and just,
it was heavy and clumsy. I,
well I had a knife on my one night
I had a knife in my, on my side.
So you're going to do it in lifestyle.
You weren't going to use the gun? No.
Well cause the gun can spoil meat.
Right? If you miss with a gun,
you could hit a shoulder which is going
to be 10 pounds of meat. You could,
you know, miss and clips and
back. You could, you know,
really the cleanest way to
do it to preserve the meat,
which is why you're doing it
so you can kill less animals.
Is with the knife to be honest.
Do you were excited about
killing it with a knife?
There's something telling you
right now that's creeping me out.
I'm thinking of you going to stray
caveman fighting an ear or you saw him.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you all of the emotions that
went through really at that point.
So just leave out Horny, right? That
didn't, that didn't cross the path. So,
you know, I mean, so we ran
a ran up there and you know,
obviously your heart's pounding
and it's a really weird experience.
And I go up and I see it
and it was still alive,
but it was probably bleeding out.
It was definitely bleeding out.
I caught a piece of the heart,
a lot of lung and uh,
it was definitely bleeding out, but I
wanted to make sure that it didn't suffer.
But at the point that I got up there,
the feeling wasn't any feeling of like,
you know,
it was nothing but just pure gratitude
and appreciation for this animal.
And I put my hand on his neck and
pulled the knife out and just, you know,
actually a very special knack to me is
one that my uncle gave to me before he
passed away. And, and I, you know,
put my hand on its neck and quiet and
myself and then put it into the heart and
I could feel the heart
reverberating through the blade
of the knife into my hand.
Whoa.
And I pulled it out and just kept my
hands on and one hand on his chest and one
hand on his neck and could
kind of sense the life,
leave the body and you know, I said
a little prayer kind of avatar style,
um, wrote one out beforehand, you know,
basically the ideas. Um, you know,
as your spirit goes back to the source
to nourish new life, may your flesh,
you know, nourish our bodies in this
life. You know, thank you system.
That's very avatar.
Like he's very avatar.
Like if you set it next to me and
I would never let me live it down,
I'd be saying thank you. Oh sister,
it's true. Why we're eating.
It would be laughing, silly bitch and
our guide would, would do the same thing.
Most of the people that know that
they would say the same thing as you.
I mean this is for me what I
needed and thought you were saying.
They would say the same time. Nobody
would say what he said. He say me.
But for me that's what I needed to say.
Like that's the way I'm
giving you a hard time.
But the reality is that's a
beautiful way of approaching it.
I mean it's just something easy to make
fun of. And I'm a hack right there.
I couldn't let it go, but then
so are I. Look at its eyes,
its face and its face was
covered in these spines.
And so I thought it hit a cactus and
they were like all up in its eyeball and
stuff like that. And then
the, I smelled the flick,
I hear the flick of a lighter
and a cigarette and it's
our, you know, country guy.
He got like a Budweiser and a cigarette.
I don't know. He's south Texas guy.
He says, oh, porcupines
spines, you know, you,
you won't see that one
time and a thousand.
And so basically some porcupine had
whacked it in the face and the spines were
working their way through its eyeball.
So it was like kind of a cool feeling
to know that at that point, you know,
I had taken an animal out of
its misery, so to speak, to,
which was not necessarily my idea.
You know,
I was going to take an
animal that presented it,
but that happened to be the
one that presented itself.
But then the really weird thing happened,
I got really angry at the porcupine,
like my love for the animal,
my appreciation for the animal was so
strong and I fucking hated that porcupine.
Really? Like, I felt like that was an
enemy. Like if someone tapped your sister,
yeah, no pork, you ban. All
it did is poking in the,
yeah, you fucking stabbed it.
But that's what [inaudible] Detroit on
that fucking poor deer. And you're like,
Conti Patti Pie. That's what's ironic is
that, I mean, I'm the killer. I killed it.
The porcupine was just doing its thing.
But I hated the porcupine.
Like it was something that like slapped
a friend of mine. That's so weird. Yeah.
Well I guess you had an intense
experience with it. So then you know,
and then from there we went
there and skinned it. You know,
you have to avoid the stomach because
the stomach smells like old guacamole,
smells terrible. It's like, try not to
puncture that. I got a little nick in it,
but I did pretty good job. And then you
clear all the guts out and then, you know,
cut all the pieces away.
But then we went fully from there,
just skinning it and then butchering
it entirely. And it was cool to feel,
you know, the best part of the meat is
the tenderloin, you know, that's what,
you know, these flaming,
known chateau beyond.
That's what all this tenderloin meat is.
It's really tender.
But not until I was up in,
they're actually cutting the tenderloin
out and feeling what it felt like.
It feels more like organ meat than regular
meat. You know? Did I understand like,
oh, this is different part
of the animal. You know,
this part of the animal is up inside,
like the cavity stuff.
It's not on the exterior part, so
it works less. It's just different.
It feels different and that's
why it tastes so delicious.
And then the other parts like
the haunches, the back strap,
they have a kind of a
more sinewy grittier feel.
What the backdrop is the up along the
spine. That is the Loin? Yeah, no,
the backstrap backstrap is right
along the spine, right on either side.
On the exterior. The tenderloin is
actually up inside the animal underneath,
like you go inside the rib cage.
So it's covered.
Actually it's another section of it.
No,
it's completely different
section backstrap backstrap
is alongside of the spine
and then the tenderloin is up underneath
the animal part of the internal muscles
that move the legs as well.
There's a really cool video
of a dude taking apart a pig.
I have it on my Twitter. If you want
to see it. It's kind of fucked up.
Like I, it's on my Twitter from a while
ago. So I don't know, uh, what the,
uh, what the name of the video
is. See if you can find it, Brian,
cause I know you're not doing
anything else. You want to
show that on Ustream. Uh,
I think you can dude taking apart the pig.
But my point is when you watch it,
like you watched like the,
like they're oh well that there's bacon.
Oh well there's the ham hocks.
Oh that is that. There's this,
there's the pork loin. There's the,
when you, when you're watching it,
like be dissected from an actual pig
broken down and he does it in like three
minutes. They're fast. Yeah. This guy
just hacks through this fucking thing.
He uses a saw and some spots.
This isn't it. This is,
this is taken apart.
But this has taken a part of cooked pig.
This guy's got a raw one that's, that's
the one you want. You want the raw pig.
I think this is probably, Yup. Well this
isn't the one that I, but I had seen,
but this is similar where they just
start slicing through and it becomes,
it goes from an animal to meet and
then it makes that weird transition.
But when you kill yourself, it never
makes that transition. Even when it's me,
it's like there's a re you,
when you put that steak on the grill and
your seasoning it and you're cooking it,
like this is a weird connection with that
animal. That's the fucking literally,
absolutely. Most people
don't get that. You know,
they don't ever have a chance to get that.
Yeah. And it's a, it's definitely
something, something completely different.
It changes your whole opinion
of the meat and you know,
probably there's some,
there's some placebo effect
in there because of your
emotional state towards the
animal. But there's also, you know,
really feels like there's something
tangible there too. You know, some,
some deeper appreciation that
actually manifests and I don't know,
I mean your mind is so important in so
many bodily functions to think that your
mind couldn't affect your digestion
or absorption or things like that.
I don't think that's unreasonable either.
But whatever it is,
whether it's tangible or
whether it's mental, you know,
the connection and the way
that you approach and digest,
assimilate that meat, which was, you
know, energy from another animal.
It's just different.
Yeah.
And even if it's not,
I mean it is healthy and if you think
it's different, it becomes different. Yup.
If you have this even like you can't,
it's hard to dismiss the
emotional connection that
you have to it because that
emotional connection is very important.
It is emotional connections or
something that people poo poo. Oh,
you're just emotionally attached to
that. Well maybe it's good. You know,
maybe it's something that you
like, you know, keep that thing,
whatever the fuck we're talking about.
Emotional connections
is not necessarily bad.
And if you have an emotional
connection like that,
it would make the meat feel better.
Make you feel better. Like, oh,
about your sustenance. Every time
we cook this deer, we're pumped.
We're excited about it. Oh, this tastes
so good. And it really does taste good.
But just the feeling of
having gone out there and you
know, caught it, butchered it,
put it in our freezer
and then cooked it up.
It's like a connection to something that
you know our ancestors had been doing
for thousands of years.
Yeah. Really it is. It's weird. Even when
you're doing it in a place with fences.
Yeah. No, I mean it's, it's not like going
to Africa and taken out a wild zebra,
which by the way apparently are delicious.
Apparently Zebra stays good.
I never had a horse before until I went
to Joe beef and Montreal and they served
as horse hallmark. God, it's God
damn delicious. A lot of coke.
A lot of Mars hate you saying that man.
The hate. You're saying that and I,
I get it. I've seen people in their
horses that's like their dog, right?
It's pony better. I want to, it's probably
like more tender, smaller. I don't know.
The Shetland ponies are the
top. Top, fast, right? Yeah.
Anything with like the crazy pompom
feet don't probably crazy ass
Budweiser. Horses. Yeah, those
are big fucking whores too, man.
What did they Chippendale's? What
are they called? A clydesdale
that was going to be big stallions. Too
Bad. Oh, you went with the gay boys.
So when you went with the Chinese
voice earlier in the gay voice,
now you sign of a bitch.
You son of a bitch. So the,
what we would do if we were going to have
a an on it hunting thing is basically
just used that ranch and you know,
just work it through like they could
do it through us, through our website.
We explain it, maybe map out your
experience, Whitney's experience,
and I'm going to go there as soon to my
experience. I want to shoot a buffalo.
I got a bit and in people
like it's not very sporting.
I just want to eat a buffalo and
I want to shoot. To me, I want it.
I have a giant freezer and I'm going
to set it up to eat my own meat.
I just think it's the smart way to do it.
I think it's the healthiest way to do
it and I think that wild game like that,
whether it's buffalo or
deer and especially venison,
I think is like the most delicious meat
on earth. Elk is absolutely delicious.
It's really the smart thing to
do. If you can do it, if you can,
if you have the time, if you have the
finances to go to a place and, and hunt.
It's really the smartest way to
gather me. And yeah, it just,
it's the way we really should all do it.
And if we did,
we would have a totally different sense
of like this connection between man and
nature. Absolutely. Yeah.
And you could combine it with a lot of
other cool stuff we could do, you know,
Kettlebell training workouts,
s club and the day get people
familiarized with that aspect, you know,
have some talks and discussions about
different things and the nights and make a
cool experience out of it.
The problem is is that you can't really
get that many people with guns together
at the same time. And we got
a lot of awesome customers.
They want to go do that.
So it's like, you know, can we, can we do
these things at 10 at a time every day?
I don't think so. You know Gail, ability
of the gun thing is really challenging,
but we're going to try and
get some face to face. Some,
some kind of program is smart to do
with the gun thing is to let them do it.
Let the branch do it.
We don't have,
because you don't want to put people
with psychos like we're going to have a
four of you are going to go hunting
together and one guy was just shooting the
ground under his feet trying to
rocket jump. You know what I mean?
You never know what the fuck
you're getting into when
you meet random strangers.
It just a we all, we all love Alpha
brain. I love Outbrain, Outbrain,
let's play most dangerous
game rock, paper,
scissors to go who gets
killed? Like tag. Yeah,
there's a lot of nuts out there as well,
I'm trying to say but,
but having a place where you know you
have like a gathering of the Juggalos type
situation for audit fans.
Everybody gets together and does battle
rubs till they throw up in the garbage.
Fucking truth texts,
amazingly chest bump and it sounds like
a natural progression for on it to start
hunting. Well not on start
hunting but on it have um,
have, uh, an option where we, you know,
we connect you with one of those places.
That would be,
it would be a cool project.
Love to have like a Ted Nugent style
set up and it's definitely not,
it's the same as going out until like
the woods of Alaska and going and getting
a brown bear.
And I would call it is there and you
call it conscious meet acquisition. Yes.
That's great.
It's like you're acquiring your meat in
a conscious way and that's really it.
It happens to be at the, you know,
at the tip of a rifle. But yeah,
that's really what you're about to laser
that laser tag hunting with animals.
Well, it's a funny thing
man, to do that with photos.
People love try to get the crosshair.
Yeah, they do that. They close up on them.
It's really dangerous. And Mountain Lions
people tried to do that. Um, the um,
fuck photo tag. What did laser
tag is where you wear like a vast,
right? Yeah. Well,
yeah. Well you could put
like best on an animal,
like a cat,
just have a laser tag tag cat ranch
and you just try to shoot him because
they're fast.
People don't have any problem with fishing
in a place where they stock the fish.
Like nobody has a problem with that.
You go to a lake and the fish are in the
lake, like are they stocked it recently?
It's great and catch big trout.
But if you go like to a fence
in place and hunting an animal,
you're a piece of shit.
Yeah, yeah. I, you know, I guess the
Mammo thing, you know, fish don't seem,
they're so different from us. I had a
cool experience fishing though recently.
I've always gone rod and reel
fishing and that's really foreign.
You're just kind of waiting around.
Then all of a sudden, oh shit.
And he grabbed the rod and reel it in
and you hope you get something and then
someone you know whacks it
on the head and you know,
maybe you pull the hook out if you're
brave and sometimes you're with somebody
who does it, whatever that whole
program is, it's, it's different.
But I went spearfishing recently,
which was kind of like a little bit
of a different paradigm as well.
That one feels a lot different.
It's like hunting,
but for fish instead of fishing cause
you're out free diving with this,
the last big wooden,
you know,
archaic looking thing with these bungee
cords hooked to this little metal spear
and you're just free diving
down, you know, eight,
10 feet and chasing after these fish and
trying to spear them. So what it does,
is it a spear gun? Yeah. So basically
it's an old triggers field gun.
The trigger releases the Bungee cord.
So you wrap these bungee cords like this,
you pull them manually and they go
on this little rod right in this,
the spear slides in a groove and the
bungee cords or behind the Rod. Right.
And then when you pull the trigger,
it just releases the thing
that's holding the bungee cords,
like a rubber band gun kind of.
And so it releases that
and that propels the, the,
the spear forward through the groove
and the spear is attached to a cord,
right? So the bungee cords, it's all full
manual energy. You pull the cords back,
wrap it around and then
release it in the bungees go.
But it's really particularly challenging
because as soon as the spear hits the
water,
it starts to dive a little bit.
It doesn't always go perfectly straight
because of resistance. It's not like air.
So, um, you know,
good people who are good could
probably do it, you know, 12 feet,
15 feet, maybe even, maybe even farther.
People who suck, like me initially,
like I had to get like right up on
these fish to get, I'm like six feet,
eight feet. How many did you do miss
before you got one time fucking done?
I was missing him constantly. And you're
swimming around in his hard current.
But the cool thing is is some of the
fish you can catch with the hook.
Like you can get snapper, which is really
delicious. But the guide on the boat,
and I was down in Mexico during this
guide and the boat was telling me that
parrot fish tastes like lobster
and I should really get pair fish.
Well Parrot fish are these little,
they have this little tiny mouth.
All they do is eat algae and you never
catch them with a hook because you can
never get a hook and they're little tiny
mouth cause you got nothing they want
to eat that's on a hook unless you
gotta really algae hook or whatever.
But it would never happen.
So with spear phishing you can actually
target these fish and so we got one
actually Whitney got, I didn't get
it. I fucking kept missing them.
She was way more gangster with
a spear gun on that. But anyway,
so she got one of these therapists and
then we brought it back to the boat and I
was really curious to eat it.
We brought it in,
the chef's cooked it right away and he
who is fucking delicious best line ever.
One of the best fish I ever had.
It was like a cross between like a
nice flaky white fish and like lobster,
like somewhere in the middle.
Wow. It had that kind of,
that richer kind of
crustacean taste and texture.
I want to go there and kill one
just to eat. It was so good.
We had that and I had
trigger fish Svi Che,
which is another type of fish
that you would never catch.
So it opens up the possibilities
and these Fisher plentiful,
it's not like there's endangered,
they're endangered species
and any sharks I didn't,
but that's dangerous when you're spear
phishing because the sharks will,
you know,
know that there's fee.
Cause when you hit the fish
there's fish guts exploding Jesus.
So if there are sharks,
it's not an optimal situation.
So doing it like off South African coast,
bad idea.
Some dude just carjack Jack
in France on this honeymoon.
Tiger Shark. And, uh, I do
not know what charcot was,
but I do know that he was the third
guy in two years to get Jack there.
Too many for my cows.
You know what they should have?
They should have a restaurant.
They have these in Japan where it's just
like this humongous saltwater pool in
the middle where you guys talking about
where you fished and you catch your own
dinner and it seems like
more places would have that.
Like you just have pretty much a huge
aquarium and you kind of get the fun of
catching your own fish and
then eating it on top of it.
Back when I was thinking of
silly Las Vegas restaurant ideas,
I thought of an idea where you had that
with like lobsters and crabs and all
kinds of stuff and that you
could tell them a mermaid,
someone with a mermaid fin to go down
and you'd point to the one you want and
the mermaid or to, okay,
that's the one you want.
She'd dive down and swim
and grab it for you.
And everybody could sit around the tank
and watch the mermaid swimming around
there. There's a, there's anybody here
that idea once I take it, go ahead.
I don't need any credit. I just want
to go, just give me a reservation.
There's a bar in Sacramento called I
think the mermaid bar where it's just this
huge long bar.
And on the top there's this humongous
a aquarium and that they just have hot
chicks in a mermaid outfit
just swimming back and forth.
And it's so eerie to just see like this
mermaid shake just swimming and Bobby.
But what sucks is everyone's
just sits there and takes photos.
Like no one's even talking. They're just
taking photos of the mermaid. Right.
And there's no real point to,
it feels gimmicky.
Like if they were actually fetching,
fetching stuff, watching stuff,
working for you, or maybe,
you know, they're trying to
catch it with a net. Like,
do you have fish in there,
like you're saying? Yeah.
They also have this a restaurant.
I've been researching a lot
of things in Japan lately,
but they have this restaurant
called the no panties,
a restaurant where they
have, they have this, no,
you were going to say that they have this,
uh, this, this thing, uh, what's, uh,
like a conveyor belt
going around the top of
the restaurant and they
just have huge dishes.
And so you just go there to
your waitress and you're like,
I would like that roast beef.
And then she sits,
stands up on this like thing that get it.
Why did you choose those beef?
And she's got no panic and she's got
no panties on and it's a party support
restaurants like this in America.
I mean if you really like to grow,
you would be constantly
getting more dishes, more food.
What do you think that Americans is to
savage and that people would just start
grabbing her and they wouldn't be
able to just let her do that I guess.
I mean if there's not many restaurants
like that in America anyway that are
crazy, like there's that restaurant
Dick's where everyone's, they just like,
or an asshole to you the whole time.
I would not email.
I can think that most partners,
most spouses and you know in
America just would not allow.
It would not go there and
we're not allowed to husbands
or boyfriends or anybody.
You could go there, period. Ever.
It's not exactly felt like no dogs.
Restaurants like have a Hooters where
they're just just no top. Well they do.
I mean that place in Florida that
we went to a strip club, right.
They serve wings and there's no
tops. Yeah. It's already been done.
Rachel's best food ever. Yeah. There's a,
there's nothing wrong with looking at
a little box where you're having some
roast beef on that little
vagina and just like,
there's nothing wrong for the gals to
to go to Cox and get some chicken while
dudes are swinging dicks in front of
him. Hot Dogs. They really wanted,
what's wrong with it? Nothing. It's
nothing wrong with it. Whatever they want.
Let them do what they want. Right.
Isn't that, wouldn't that be better?
And let us all decide what we actually
like set of confusion the shit out of
Catholic school girls by
telling him the caucus bad.
Who's the biggest freaks ever? Right.
Catholic school there were oppressed.
Did you ever have a Catholic
school girl experience? Yeah.
One of my first girlfriends
in Catholic high school,
all girls high school and every one,
every girl in that class was rabid,
rabid. They got ahold of some cock.
As soon as they got out of school,
they would just start jerking dudes off.
They couldn't help themselves.
They were in a trance.
Anytime we repressed those naturally,
it's not going to get everything
all. That's fascinating, isn't it?
That girl was easily one of the,
like most sexually explosive
girls I had ever dated ever.
Like it was like as soon as you would
start making out, she would go full,
like say tannic possession.
It was insane.
It was rich with so many other emotions
of sin and danger and all of these
things wrapped up with an already
exciting sexual experience. Yeah,
it's just too much.
Yeah,
and we were both 17 fuck you're doing
when you're 17 you're just, you're,
you're like just a meat machine.
Just moving to the whim of hormones.
Dick Pills. That's what happens to me.
It's not though. It's not the same.
It's not the same.
You're forcing it and you're like,
oh good papa glug, glug, glug, glug.
There's a big difference between that and
when you do remember those 17 year old
boners, those things were ridiculous. They
would hurt your dick would get so hard.
It would hurt my dick felt like I was
going to blow up this morning cause yeah,
but you're on pills.
Some wacky fucking shit that you got it.
Account store.
I had to do the thing where I had to
take a shit when I woke up this morning.
So I had to like have a bucket that I
usually use to calm your dog and so I
could pee in a bucket.
What?
Cause I couldn't Tuck my dick
down while I was shitting.
Well you got to learn how
to have better balance.
You gotta look at it like
doing a downward dog.
I just grab a hold of the
top of the lid of the,
you know the top where the upper deck
is, right. And then just bend down.
Push your dick down. Yeah,
but don't push your ball.
Don't push your ball style so far back
that it gets in the way. Your Shit. Yeah.
Cause that's going to slide right down.
You're going to have to do one at a time.
That's where you going.
I couldn't have to rock bottom before.
I mean when you guys, Shit,
you can't really stop that p.
That's like a p that
you can't stop whining.
You're shitting because it will stop
the shit also. You know what I mean?
And then if he tried to stop it
that deeply, but now I'm forced to.
I don't think I've ever actually
shit with above. I just wait.
Brian is constantly on site
all day,
every day. Can't get rid of boners.
It's affecting the way shit.
He's like holding it in because he knows
his boner lasts for six hours and other
three hours I'll be able to shit.
Yeah.
So one of,
one of the stories I've been reading
after reading Danieli Billy's book,
I went back and reread some of
my, uh, biographies of Rasputin.
Oh yeah. You want to as Dick.
Yeah. Freak pastured has,
apparently he had a foot long Dick
with award. At the root of it.
They killed the guy. Well,
apparently there's pull it up, Brian.
This is Prince Putin's
cock. Prince Paul was, uh,
apparently tried to make
homosexual advances at respite
and it wasn't feeling it.
Rasputin was the old hard drinking
Siberia and peasant wizard and he liked
women.
And that was part of the adaptations
he made to his religion is that he was,
he always struggled with the fact that,
you know,
you couldn't have sex and Christianity,
but he wanted to be, you know,
man of deep faith. Brian's right there
under Google images. Rasputin's cocked.
They really do have it.
Holy Shit. So, so yeah,
you put it up. He would, he would go in.
I struggle with it.
You're allowed to have that on Ustream.
I talked to Brad today. It
looks like a potato. And
look at that. That is Rasputin's deck.
But apparently he could, he could base.
So he made an exception in yeah.
And his
religion. He, uh, he saw some birds
singing in the print. This is his story.
The birds were singing and they were
moved by sexual desire to sing such a
beautiful song.
And if the God made the birds sing to
create such a song and bring that out of
them, then man's sexual desire
must be for the same thing.
And then he had this
revelation in the forest,
probably eating m Anita miscarry mushrooms
and then apparently came across three
women,
three women bathing,
and he made love to each of them in turn
and then prayed more clearly than he'd
prayed in months. And it was
solidified. Yeah. Really,
because your mind is totally,
Chris Dodd was a giant Dick. Fuck yeah.
After that point he was like, okay,
so God didn't strike me down and
I'm praying better than ever.
So he adapted that to is a kind of
philosophy, but apparently he had,
it was kind of a, a bit of a
hypnotist, wizard, whatever.
I don't know how far you
want to go with his powers,
but the reports were that
he could contract and dilate
his pupils that will like
through mental control so
he could do like weird shit.
And he had a huge Dick and we just made
just cut a swath through all of Russia.
Everybody was able to
dilate his pupils at will.
It probably means he was
on drugs. Probably. Yeah,
most likely giant Dick Dude on drugs.
And that's where they didn't cut it off
at that and it looks like they went in
and kind of dug some of the dick out,
what they had to do to kill him.
So apparently this guy used to pull
for the bulb item, a lot of Poland,
a lot of people didn't like him.
They hated him for it.
He was probably fucked everybody.
There was accusations that he was fucking
this Arrieta and cause he was healing
Tsar Nicholas The sun. So
all these kind of, you know,
people were jealous at one point,
one point he was having so much sex.
He loved drinking and dancing and fucking,
and he was in this bar and he's
all haggard and they're like,
you're not Rasputin. And he's
like, like hell, I'm not.
And he pulled his pants down and waved
to dick around and it was like, oh,
your ass beat and okay,
whatever. Damn. But anyways,
this one guy wanted to prince USIP of
apparently wanting to have sex with,
rescued,
rescued and wasn't down with it.
And the tide of the tide kind of turned
against them and popular culture and he
told his family that he
was probably going to die.
So they go there and they start
feeding him cyanide cakes, right.
And apparently fed him enough cyanide
cakes to kill many, many people.
But that didn't work.
Rasputin got a little bit sick and then
he kept eating the cakes and he was like,
play me some gypsy music. Used to pop and
started dancing. They're like, oh fuck,
this isn't working. So then
they, then they took out a gun,
shot him in his back, Bam, Bam.
Shot him right in the torso and his back
and he apparently just roared like a
bear and stared at him.
So they all freaked out
and started kicking him and
stomping him and kicked his
head and kicked him so hard that his
eyeball fell out and just totally beat him
to a bloody pulp and then
wrapped them in a carpet,
wrapped them in change and
threw him in a frozen river.
And then when they found the body washed
up, he didn't die of any of that shit.
He died of drowning because they had the
water that they saw in his lungs from
him gasping for air.
So whatever the fuck was,
this guy was doing you as a
strong motherfucker like no,
they were not really unhappy with
him. Dude. His Dick was 11 inches.
That's big. And it's thick as most
men's risks. That's what it says.
The Russian women were all about it.
That is incredible.
The dude was just super gangster.
What do you mean it doesn't look that big?
It's bigger than that chick's whole
entire head. It's soft, dude. Oh,
you son of a bitch.
I don't think you're allowed to do that.
Brad from Ustream will frown
upon those kinds of Shenanigans.
We don't want to get them in trouble.
Brian. I think I found the big foot.
Look in the jar.
Shut the fuck off to stop.
I've been talking to too many
big foot people, man. This, this,
this show has been very fascinating.
I'm learning a lot.
I can't wait to talk about it,
but I can't talk about it yet because
I'm learning a lot weren't crazy people.
Sun Sasquatch is to,
Oh,
I'm wearing a lot about everything.
It's all connected. It's all,
it's all connected cycles. Psychic,
Sasquatch, the whole thing.
Ufos. No, no shape my balls.
Um, trim, Trim. The upper stack.
Do you put shaving cream on
or you just lightly glide the,
I'm glad you asked Brian. I like to use
a double blade, razor and defense soap.
I lather up the old sacker Rooney,
get it nice and primed with soap.
And then just the razors of today,
you don't need to go five bucks.
I don't know how many blades are
on there cause I can't count.
So I just get in there,
whatever it says. Never son.
These razors are so good these days.
You're not going to nick it unless
you're not paying attention.
What about asshole? I let that go. He's
like, oh I let welcome to the jungle.
We got fun and Games. I don't know what's
going on back there. I leave it alone.
I wash it whenever possible and ignore it.
I guess like a squirrel with a bullet
wasn't very happy with the balls forward.
Everything back outsider,
I dunno.
I Dunno where it fits in the equation and
I want them to do their rake went over
it. My Shit usually looks
like like it's like a lot of,
there's a lot of green in
there like chunks of leafy
vegetables until I gorge on
meat and then it becomes a hard chunky.
Brian,
do you think that hairy vaginas
are can making a comeback? Yeah,
they are,
but I mean there's two different kinds.
There's the ones that they've always had
the hairy vagina and then there's the
girls that recently like I'm taking care
of this and bring it back because I,
there was one recently where it
was just like, no, this has not,
this is like seventies vagina.
That hasn't been touched since the 70s
and I think that that's a little too much.
Yeah, that's too much. That's
discussing. I don't, I, I, you know what,
I like it completely shaved.
Yeah. Nothing wrong with that
either. It's interesting though,
what a total victory porn has had over
the way women take care of their vaginas.
Complete. Damon took Dave internalized
the whole philosophy. Yeah.
Well they had to keep up.
They had to compete.
Too many guys were like looking at these
perfectly shaved vaginas and with girls
licking them and you know,
beaten off to him and then the
women catch them and I'm like, Oh,
this mother fucker likes this shit.
I got to shave it all down.
And like the little Hitler ones that
the girls do that almost like, hey,
you're putting an eyelash or an eyebrow
on your pussy. That's creepier to me.
Then having,
here's the
man, I never had a problem with
the big Bush. You know, when,
when girls started trimming it all down,
I was like, yeah, I guess that's better.
But do you remember like when you were
in high school and girls never shaved it?
It was always craziness down
there. It was chaos down there. Do.
You didn't get upset. You know,
you didn't get bummed out.
You remember like we tell stories like
dude, all the way up to her assholes,
just can't remember where I
fucking a year over a back,
and this is a girl that I dated who
had hair. She had hair everywhere.
I mean it was crazy. She had like
her lower back was Harry, you know,
she was hot as fuck though,
Dude. It didn't matter.
She was just cannot deal with
that. Oh, you could have, trust me.
You could've dealt with it.
I'm definitely down with the whole Harry,
the whole thing down there. But then
the armpits still in the last, I can't,
I can't deal with that. Yeah,
I'm not even good with that.
When I see a little light
fuzz on their cheek,
you know when the sunlight
hits it, right. Creeps.
But the armpits and like even
the hairy legs, not so much,
but the armpits still fucked me up.
I was friends with a gal who went
to an all girls college in um,
in Boston. I forget which one, but
it's super, she was super left wing,
like the most left wing person
ever dated like vegetarian,
like full on her friends and
shaved their legs at all.
She didn't shave her legs either,
but she was blonde so you couldn't tell.
But her friend looked like a hobbit.
It was the strangest thing ever.
I W W whenever house, her friend
was Greek and she had hobbit legs,
her legs would just black with hair and
black feet and I'm complete and total
hypocrite to say there's
something wrong with that.
Complete total hypocrites doesn't
really fit at all. Well, how could I,
how dare I say anything?
It's true. There's wrong with
that. If that's her choice,
but damn it was gross.
Didn't matter.
I have no business thinking it's gross.
I'm fucking grocer for sure.
But it was gross. I had to get out
of there. It was freaking me out.
It's fucking hairy feet. It was
just so weird. They were so weird.
They were like, they were, they were
both. They both came from money,
money and educated parents and they were
like just fucking fighting the power
tooth and claw and I guess
I really appreciate that.
And then a lot of ways like,
you know,
if you have like really oppressive parents
are very strict parents and once you
very rigid in their focus,
you want to break away from that and
like make it warm. Completely radical.
Opposing opinions make a statement.
But when the armpit hair starts creeping,
like I'm in a new beach that's
creeping over onto the tit, you know,
if you ever did he go here and
it says on the nipples. Yeah.
Big hitters that they didn't do a
daily down the Nipples, right? Yup.
[inaudible]
back to weird places there now Joe,
Esther head one really long
and it got caught in my,
between my two front teeth and it
plucked and she screamed, Jesus son,
that's not true. Wow. He
just got called outside.
You just got called the fuck out now.
And you need to tell the truth though.
Is it true or is it not true?
Yeah, it's true. Totally true.
Brian. Sorry. Apologize. No
perfect person right there.
All right, let's get the fuck out
of here. It's late. It's 10 30.
I've been working all day talking to crazy
people and I can talk to a senator to
him about Ufo Ufos.
Can wait to tell you,
but you got an a half to a, if anybody
hasn't seen any of my latest videos,
I just did one on the psychedelic
experience. Pretty cool.
Please try and check it
out. Doing like these, uh,
Jason [inaudible] pills and they're
fucking good man. What was that?
The one on the psychedelic experience
just called the psychedelic experience.
vimeo.com/warrior poet us now
can check them out. It's fun.
That's a very good one. It's
very fun. I enjoy it very much.
I liked that you do in that two man.
And it's really easy to
criticize those things.
It's really easy to mock
them and make fun of. And uh,
if you were in front
of me when you did it,
I probably would have mocked you a little
bit. But it's not that it's not good.
It's trying to put some,
put some info out there.
You know the right vibes out there and
that's the problem with the right vibes
as they'd been co opted by silly
douche bag. So if you get in that mix,
that energy vibe, love mix, you can,
you know immediately like what bitch,
what are you doing?
What are you trying to do over there?
And you started to call you a and
you fuckhead you know it's like no,
you're trying to do the right thing,
but there's so many people that aren't,
that are mixed up in the
same vein. I, that's why,
I mean I hear going to burning man's a
lot of fun. Good fucking luck with that.
Good luck with that because this is at
least 10 dudes there that you do not ever
want to be stuck talking to and they're
there in a tent right next to you.
Just at least 10 dudes,
10 dude that a 20 I would say
maybe let's be super generous.
If Bernie man has 50,000 people,
I don't know how many people would ask
if it has 50,000 people and 10 of them
are just insufferable twats
why would you go right?
Maybe because 10 of them are
unimpossible inspirations,
but the people that go to Brian, man,
I know so many cool people that go,
there's a lot of fuck crampy.
Hancock goes and so you'd go for though.
You figure those guys balance out the
comments. If you could stay with them,
stick close to the herd, don't
stress. It just sounds like a lot of,
it's pretty intense. It's dust
everywhere. Just no sandwiches
bartering forever. I can't
probably. Awesome. We've never gone.
How can we talk about coffee?
We're talking to you about
something we never did.
We got to go. Sorry. I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. Listen,
all of you people out
there enjoying burning man.
Why are you listening to
the fear factor guy? Okay.
Make up your own mind about shit.
I don't even believe what I say.
I'm just trying to fill three hours and
entertain you in some way and if you're
tired of me, I'm tired of me too, so
it's okay. It's all good. Have Fox,
this episode is brought to you by hover.
Please go to hover.com forward slash
Rogen and get 10% off your domain name
registrations.
You sexy bitches.
It's also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com if you go to o n n I t and use
the code name Rogan, you will save
10% off any an all supplements.
Go and check out all the cool new shit
we have if you haven't been there for a
while.
We got a lot of new stuff.
So a lot of food killer bee honey cause
it's gangster and a human optimization.
That's the goal and thanks
to all the customers out
there. You guys are some bad,
bad motherfuckers are great people.
I've really enjoyed interacting
with all you guys and
I just hope that we can continue to be
some small part in pushing you towards
whatever your,
you know,
masterpiece of life is going to be
whatever going to help you be better.
I hope we can just play that small
part and I certainly appreciate all the
support we've had.
It's been amazing.
Massive amount of positive people and
you put it out there and it comes back to
you. That's it. That's why
a whatever. That's it folks.
We love the fuck out of you.
That's all. We're trying to
start slow bunch of fancy words.
It's just really this in a hug. We
love you. Check me out on Facebook.
I'm super active on there, so if you want
to talk to me, hit me up on Facebook,
facebook.com/warrior poet.
U S yeah, it's Twitter.
It's a warrior poet us on Twitter
as well. All right, you freaks.
We love the shit out of you
and we will see you soon.
Bye.